Okay,
boom.
We're alive.
That's it.
Just like that.
So thank you for doing this.
Welcome.
What's going on?
Total pleasure.
Nothing.
Happy to be in La are you?
I am always New York's could right now
though.
Right?
It's good.
It's like June ish.
It's like an addictive relationship,
but most of us would rather be in
California.
New York is,
yeah,
yeah.
It's,
um,
you're a psychiatrist and um,
I would think that there was ample work
in New York,
just the environment that New York
provides people stacked on top of each
other,
like that beep,
beep Hong Kong.
Fuck you all that like,
I would just assume all that stress
leads to a lot of people with a,
yeah,
absolutely.
It's like if you're a fisherman,
you want to live near a river.
Right?
Right.
And it's fetishized in New York too,
to have a psychiatrist.
It's sort of almost expected that you
do.
So not only is there like ample supply
and demand,
but then it's,
you know,
it's a thing you're talking about.
Yeah.
What,
what's that about?
Can you explain that?
I think it's like,
you know,
Woody Allen level,
right?
Like sort of embracing your shadow and
then there's something refreshing about
it because we don't pretend to be okay.
I mean we're deeply not okay in New
York.
Chronically bullied someone.
Okay.
Like in general anywhere.
Is there a spot like,
oh yeah,
Seattle,
they've got it nailed.
I mean there's this term actually in the
medical literature,
believe it or not,
called Paleo deficit disorder and it
just refers to like how far have you
strayed from the path in your lifestyle?
Like basic stuff,
greenspace movement,
you know,
sleep.
And I would imagine that if you have
more of those components intact,
you're probably a bit more okay than if
you're living,
you know,
right.
In midtown Manhattan,
like Seattle in the summer to me is a
really good place because it's so green
and it's so pretty.
And the ocean's right there.
So you're getting some good air and then
you're getting sun cause it's the
summer.
So you don't have to seasonal depression
thing that goes on.
I mean I imagine they're doing better.
They're doing it,
they've been there.
You never know.
I've heard it's like crazy beautiful.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
It's awesome.
But those winners,
they get to you after the 30th day
around and you're like,
come on,
this is stupid.
Like how much water do you need?
I'm like a big,
big winter complainer and I have been my
whole life.
So I complain 10 months of the year of
what it's like to live in the northeast.
But recently I've been playing around
with the idea that there's actually
something cool about like,
you know,
sort of cyclical living.
It's almost just like if you embrace it,
then there's something just like
everything did and miserable for a
period of time and then it blooms.
You're getting to experience like this
rebirth and then it,
you know,
flourishes and then it dies again.
But there's another perspective on that
actually being,
I don't know,
like if you work with it,
it's sorta like a woman who's on birth
control
has no idea that there's any point to,
uh,
you know,
a cycle of energy over the course of the
month range.
She sort of thinks is that,
that's annoying.
But there's a way you can wrap your mind
around it where you work.
Okay.
So like if you're on birth control,
you have no menstrual cycle,
right?
So you're just like,
you're like a man,
you're like a flat line the whole month.
But there's actually something really
empowering if you understand how to work
with your energy shifts because
naturally like a woman's natural men,
I know this is really what you want to
be talking about,
right?
It's salient to me.
So I do want to hear like I figured this
out,
I'm 39 I was on birth control for 12
years,
so I never knew what it was,
what it meant to have like a menstrual
cycle until very recently.
Cause then I had two kids breastfeeding.
So a couple of decades into my life,
I'm just figuring this out.
But you have like totally different
kinds of energy over the course of the
month and you have to know how to work
with that.
So there's a kind of energy that you
want to go out and socialize or you want
to stay in and work or you want to sleep
more or less.
And if you don't know how to ride that,
then you could be sort of taken off
guard by it.
But if you know how to work with it,
it's so much more powerful than just
having this like artificial hijacking of
your endocrine system.
That's interesting.
So there's like some sort of analogy to
be drawn between the cycles of nature
and the cycles of your body month to
month.
Yeah.
Huh.
I would have never considered that.
I never even thought about it,
but I have thought about birth control
before about how crazy it is that you
give a woman a hormone that convinces
her body that she's perpetually pregnant
and that a giant percentage of women are
on it for convenience or even from other
medical issues like skin issues.
Right,
exactly.
Yeah.
I mean when I,
I've always been a feminist,
right?
So even when I was younger and very much
asleep,
I identified as a feminist and I was one
of those people who thought that birth
control was like a female entitlement.
Like how dare you not make this free and
widely available.
But as I began to research more about it
and more about how it's in many ways
like the ultimate,
you know,
not to sound too inflammatory,
but the ultimate tool for oppression of
you know,
the modern woman now I find it
incredible that we,
you know,
there were still taking it because it
seems like a good idea,
right?
Who wants to deal with your annoying
menstrual cycle?
Who wants to get pregnant,
who wants to have endometriosis or
polycystic ovary,
you know,
who wants to have acne or like hair
growing in weird places.
But it's the magic pill illusion.
There's no free lunch,
there's never going to be something that
just fixes it for you and you just waltz
off into the sunset.
There's always a cost and the cost is so
much more vast,
like ranging from literally death all
the way to just like subtle alterations
in your personality.
And like the fear Moans,
you secrete,
you know,
and there there was just a million woman
study,
um,
and Scandinavia that showed about the
vast increase in antidepressant
prescribing for teenagers who are
prescribed birth control.
So it's the beginning of sort of,
it's like a gateway drug sometimes for
psych meds to her.
I had a friend who,
one of his good friends,
his daughter died from some
complications with taking birth control
pills and smoking cigarettes.
Yes,
pulmonary embolism,
probably smoking cigarettes.
Apparently along with the birth control
pills are extremely dangerous,
but so many do it of course.
And you don't even have to have that
additional risk factor,
you know,
cause birth control,
whether it's the pill or something
called the Nuva ring by itself has that,
you know,
I'm contacted often by parents of girls
who have died from pulmonary embolism
who've now become like activists in this
realm.
It's because of birth control pills.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's like a known mechanism and it's a
known risk factor.
Like I think that's not being suppressed
or hidden.
It's just that we're sort of in trained
to dismiss the risks as we attached to
the promise,
so we sort of like collude and ignoring
that potential.
You know?
That's so interesting because most
people when they think about the birth
control pill,
they think about it as something that
liberated women.
Exactly.
They can control whether or not they got
pregnant and they were allowed for the
first time to have careers and do
whatever they wanted to because they
didn't have to worry about being
trapped.
That's right.
That's a story,
but that's the biological free lunch
thing,
right?
There's isn't there also a lot of
issues.
Chris Ryan was on here at Dr Chris Ryan,
the author of sex at dawn.
He was on here and he was talking about
how women can look.
If you smell the clothes of other men,
you can literally tell the men that you
are attracted to,
you would be biologically compatible
with those men and that when they did
these same studies on women who are on
the birth control pill,
they couldn't smell the difference.
That's right.
It's called the t shirt study.
Yeah.
How does that work?
Could you explain that?
Well,
essentially the,
the premise of pharmaceutical medicine
is that you can just pull like one
little thread of the spider web and
leave the rest of it intact.
Like everything else is going to be
fine.
We're only working on this one area.
So with birth control for example,
the idea is we're just,
you know,
taking over the management of your sex
hormones,
but the rest of your body is going to be
totally unaffected.
And of course as we learn more about how
all of these systems are totally an
inextricably interconnected,
we have a better understanding of how,
you know,
when you interfere with sex hormones,
you also potentially have other effects
including,
um,
raising things called binding Globulin
is including inflammatory response.
You're depleting a number of nutrients
and we're having,
you know,
it's possible that we,
we haven't even begun to look through
the keyhole of the effects on brain and
you know,
sort of neuropeptides and these arenas
where we don't have any idea what
pheromonal secretion is about.
Like we just have to defer the
probability
that our bodies are more complex than
we've.
Right and like began to understand.
So your biology is meant to guide you.
It's meant to empower you and it's meant
to create a sense of vitality.
If you can inhabit your body and be in a
truce with it.
That's part of the problem with the
mindset of birth control is I'm just
going to,
you know,
take this over.
I'm going to some manage this.
And so who knows?
Maybe even it's a top down like mindset
thing that begins to sort of divorce you
from your sensibilities.
We don't really know is the point that's
going,
that's going to be a common answer I
think I have to give you is that we,
we don't really know,
but it,
it does make sense that you're,
you know,
the subtle nature of your biology that
involves,
you know,
sort of guiding your human interactions
and particularly sex related
interactions is going to be derailed.
I mean,
low libido is one of,
ironically the most common,
um,
disclosed side effects of birth control.
So you're,
you're taking it so that you can have
unprotected sex.
We don't feel like having sex ultimately
anyways.
So it's not even really that well
thought out,
I think by most of us.
That's very bizarre.
But what other alternatives are there?
I mean if you're a woman and you want to
have control of whether or not you get
pregnant,
there's not a whole lot of options other
than weird ones like Iud,
which seemed real weird.
Yeah.
I mean there is some of my patients use
what's called a copper iud.
You know,
it's funny cause I had one put in and
two and a half,
it costs like $700 and two and a half
weeks later I had it taken out because I
just felt weird about having like a
pharmaceutical metal and mind.
And my body was about like a tracking
device.
It felt like feel it and there are no,
no,
it's not really a thing.
It's just like psychologically it felt
weird.
But um,
I use something called a daisy,
which is like this highly calibrated
thermometer.
I need track your,
you know,
cause you have six fertile days a month.
This isn't,
you know,
like some major sacrifice you have to
make in order to learn how your cycle
works and then you get the benefits of
being in your hormonal millia you know,
like it's not,
um,
it's not that complicated,
but there's a learning curve,
you know,
requires like learning how to be a woman
and also sharing the onus because you
know,
with all of these side effects had been
talking about,
you know,
there was like a male birth control
study that was just terminated because
of how many side effects like the men
didn't want to deal with.
You know,
so there's such this socio cultural
double standard around this,
but if we're talking about six days a
month,
like have we collaborate and try and
figure something out,
you know,
that doesn't involve a risk of death.
Perhaps this daisy thing just monitors
or temperature and tells you exactly
what's going on.
Yeah.
I mean it's a little more sophisticated
than that.
It actually has the efficacy like above
99% efficacy if you listen to it.
That's part of the,
you know,
room for human error,
but it basically just tells you like
have sex now if you want to conceive or
if you don't then don't.
So it's a little like a light's green,
red or yellow.
Well,
how many women are on birth control?
If you had to guess nationwide?
You know,
I would,
that's a good question.
I don't know the stat off hand.
Upwards of like 10 million I would say.
But that's a growing number of people
taking some sort of substance that
alters the,
the very nature of who they are.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I mean,
my interest in it really came from
looking at the psychiatric side effects
because I'm very interested in
medications that have potential,
you know,
gateway effects around psychiatric meds
that we aren't informing women have
before they start the prescription.
So,
you know,
whether it's like acid blocking
medications,
you know,
or antibiotics,
um,
you know,
birth control of vaccines,
these things have known a psycho
biological effects.
If you don't know that,
then you'll never connect the dots.
And then you end up in the polypharmacy
realm where you're taking multiple meds
without ever knowing where the dominoes
like started to fall.
I remember there was a commercial they
used to have,
I don't know if they're still there,
but it was for a psychiatric medication
that you take who's an antidepressant
when you are depressed from
antidepressants.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
I think you've probably talking about
abilify.
It was actually the number one
prescription in America recently.
Terrifying.
It's an anti psychotic,
you read the side effects.
It's like Whoa,
slow down.
Like what is this?
Like psychotic thoughts and death and
yeah,
bleeding and right and if what you were
taking that had similar side effects
isn't working,
then you can just layer this on.
It's very common practice.
It's very rare.
I would say actually for people to be on
just one psychiatric med.
It's almost an industry standard to be
taking upwards of,
I would say,
you know,
two,
three,
sometimes even five.
Many of the patients I work with come to
me on a cocktail of like five medics.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Well,
you're chasing something for like years,
right?
Because you're never really gonna feel
yourself the way you want to.
And that's what I've found is really
what we want.
You know,
like we just want to feel comfortable in
her own skin.
We just want to feel ourselves like in
fact,
they don't want to,
you know,
be her or him or be rich are beautiful.
We just want to feel cool being who we
are.
And you're never going to,
I don't want to say never,
but it's very unlikely you'd feel that
way while on a medication that has
consciousness altering effects and a
slew of side effects.
And so you're going to be chasing that
with other,
with the promise of other meds,
you know,
a stimulant because you're a paxil is
making you tired and then you need a
benzodiazepine because you can't sleep
and you know,
then you're sort of depressed again.
And so you have another antidepressant
layered on.
And then there's a fad,
you know,
sort of,
bipolar to medication that you could try
out like lamictal or abilify.
And so this is sort of the culturally
sanctioned approach to mental health
today.
Yeah.
So how does the doctor know?
Like say if you think they put you on
some zoloft or something like that,
and I'm not to pick on Zoloft,
but then they,
they say,
well,
it's just not really totally doing it
for Ya.
Oh,
we're thinking about stack and abilify
in with the Zoloft and I think that just
might be the ticket to your happiness.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Well it's important to remember,
right?
Like particularly in psychiatry,
there's no objective testing measure.
You have a broken arm like,
Hey,
I see you have a broken arm.
We're going to put your arm in a cast
over the broken arm.
You can get an x ray.
Right,
right.
Improve.
They have a broken arm.
Right.
In psychiatry,
there's no blood test.
There's no eeg,
there's no,
you know,
scan of any kind.
It's a conversation.
Sometimes as short as 10 minutes.
If I came into your office and my office
is a little different,
but just say if you were a regular
psychiatrist and I'm like,
ah man,
I dunno Kelly.
I'm a fucking mess.
I can't keep it together.
What do I do?
What do I take?
Could you just start someone off on like
a low dose of something and see if it
helps and they come back and a couple of
weeks like how does it work?
It's like it,
it's like an art form.
I mean you have your personal favorite
medications that you feel comfortable
prescribing so you're more likely to
prescribe them.
But then also,
and this is also,
you know in the literature itself,
if a patient comes in asking for a
particular medication,
then you 49% I think it was like of
prescriptions that are written are
written because of specific patient
requests.
So like where are people getting
exactly.
They're getting these ideas from the
fact that we are one of three countries
in the world that allows for direct to
consumer advertising.
North Korea and Russia.
No,
it's surprising.
It's surprising.
Brazil and New Zealand.
Oh Wow.
That is surprising.
It's weird,
right?
It confuses the hell out of me when I
watch those commercials and those like
beautiful piano music playing and
there's cartoon flowers are smiling and
everybody was brainwashed.
What are they selling me?
And they know it works.
Ask Your doctor multibillionaires are
put into those commercials.
Yeah,
for good reason.
So there's no real like,
there's not like a blood test or
something they give you,
they say,
I think this is going to be the ticket
for you.
Nope.
Yeah,
no,
it's very impressionistic.
And that's sort of the issue.
I mean,
the diagnostic and statistical manual,
the DSM is sort of the dictionary,
so to speak,
in psychiatry.
And like in the 50s,
it was like 150 pages and now it's 886
pages and it's grown in volume largely
because of the consensus decisions of a
bunch of older white men sitting around
a table.
You say the bane,
um,
you know,
almost all of them have industry ties.
And this is out there.
This isn't like a conspiracy theory on
my mom was a nurse and she was always
telling me that,
um,
they would,
uh,
get taken out on these really nice
dinners by these pharmaceutical
companies to take it to a real nice
restaurant,
buy steak and champagne potato and
everybody could have a drink.
And you know,
they would be so willing to be like very
complimentary of this medication.
Why?
I know a girl took this and it really
helped her a lot.
And you doctor Kinesin and I'm like,
I was in that generation to where I got
taken out to five star restaurants in
Manhattan all the time.
It's by you stuff,
it feels really good because you're
making like 20 grand a year working your
ass off.
And so when someone takes you to a fancy
restaurant with your friends,
but you could convince yourself that
it's not actually going to,
you know,
that you're an intellectual and you're
gonna make your own decisions.
But all of the data suggest otherwise
that you are unduly influenced by that
kind of courtship behavior.
And it's,
it's true.
So we have this like,
you know,
sort of collusion on the part of the
doctor and the patients to support
industry interests over any,
any sort of,
I know,
shred of a scientific or evidence based
process for really diagnosing someone,
especially when we're talking about
something that is so subjective where
it's not like a broken arm or a like a
Joe,
you've got a broken arm.
Like I know what to do,
we're going to set your arm in a cast.
It's like,
so you're feeling down,
hey man.
Right.
They even ask you like,
does this,
this does a normal cycle,
like I guess like someone who's really
good wood,
but is your diet and your sleep
patterns,
is that a consideration before they
prescribe medication medication?
No.
In fact,
um,
most sorta turncoat doctors like me will
tell you that we have one hour of
nutrition education in all of our
medical school and residency training.
One keeping you a turncoat or you like
considered like a rat bad person in the
industry.
I'm not welcome in the highly calls
anymore.
Now I lost,
saw my faculty positions and yeah.
Um,
because I guess the kind of science that
I bring to the table,
which is not my own,
I don't have any original ideas,
but I,
I am really good I think at curating
information and collecting it and
synthesizing it,
presenting it,
right.
So what I have to shine a light on is
very inconvenient,
um,
science for industry interest but also
for conventional practice because,
you know,
I don't prescribe medication anymore
under any circumstances ever.
Um,
but I do have an entire practice devoted
to taking people off of medication.
So I have sort of my thing,
and it's a lot based on lifestyle
changes you mentioned,
right?
If you don't have your methodology as an
alternative to prescribing and you're
going to what a
lot of the science says that condemns
the pharmaceutical approach,
what are you going to do instead?
You just invested $200,000
of debt,
blood,
sweat,
and tears,
indentured servitude for like a decade
of your training.
You're just going to give that up,
you know?
So it's a lot to expect.
The average psychiatrist who
acknowledge,
you know,
anything beyond what's called like
consensus medicine.
It's called that because it doesn't even
have a connection to the evidence.
It's not evidence based.
It's just they all agree on it and
they're just going to keep doing it.
You know?
So this consensus medicine,
like in psychiatry,
there's kind of like this understanding
that you don't criticize the system that
everybody's operating under.
He just work within that system.
Yeah.
Why would you bother?
You know,
cause just going to get you to be
uncomfortable for you is going to get
you in trouble and there's no incentive.
You know?
Like I read more science than probably
all my conventional colleagues put
together because I have a lot of
incentive to do so because I'm
practicing outside of the,
you know,
the gold standard so to speak.
So when you're in the fold,
why would you bother reading science?
Who Cares?
You just do what you are taught to do.
Don't question it.
You know?
So it's,
you know,
the reason that lifestyle is not
presented as a relevant factor in
conventional medicine is because it
flies in the face of the whole model,
right?
Like the model is still a gene based
model.
It's still are born with it.
You know,
it's like coddling the victim.
There's nothing you can do about it.
So you know,
you better just be a good boy and take
your medication is the only thing you
can do because diet doesn't matter,
you know,
whether you're,
huffing fumes through your window.
It doesn't matter whether you're eating
six cans of tuna day and mercury
poisoning yourself,
does it,
none of that matters really.
Maybe it's like of minor interest,
but the real problem is your inborn
genetic chemical imbalance,
right?
So if that is the premise,
and it's not just in psychiatry,
it's in all of medicine is gene based
determinism,
freeze Pharma to offer the only
solution.
And it actually validates people on some
level as the victim,
right?
So like a lot of people want to feel
weirdly,
um,
you know,
like their own victimization.
It feels comfortable.
And even though there's science that
supports that having a healthy nutrient
dense diet allows your body to produce
the all the healthy hormones and
chemicals and neurotransmitters and all
of that.
And then along with exercise,
which also increases,
it is having,
there were studies also that show that
exercise,
regular aerobics exercise in particular,
um,
it does as much to treat depression as
ssrs
more,
more actually because the efficacy of
most antidepressants is pretty
embarrassing.
Like,
you know,
to be frank because if you really dig
into the literature,
it's what you think it is.
Um,
in terms of really being a viable
treatment option,
so many of these natural alternatives
like far out pace,
I mean things even like herbs like
Tumeric or acupuncture,
Yoga,
you know,
exercise.
And that's just a single intervention.
So there's nothing miraculous about my
approach.
It's basically just putting all those
things together at once for like a
synergistic effect.
So you can send your body and mind is
like a signal of safety,
right?
And it works,
So if you're just doing one of those
things in isolation and even one of
those things is more effective than you
know,
it's really,
it really comes down to the mindset
because if you wanted an a pill,
it's going to be challenging for you to
get results through effort or something
behavioral.
So the mindset piece has become a real
focus for me as being maybe the most
important determinant of what's going to
be an effective intervention piece.
Meaning meaning what you believe like
about health and if you want to believe
that you're broken and that you know,
chemicals aren't necessary to manage
your scary body.
I've changed a lot of smart people that
believe that.
I have a friend,
she's a scientist,
she's very smart,
she's on antidepressants and if you
talked to her,
she will argue to the death and these
are critical for her life and that she
needs him.
And she has some sort of a brain
imbalance and it's no different than
having you know,
some other organ in your body.
It doesn't function properly and you
need medication for that.
We've been told,
I was told that and I believe that for
sure.
You know,
the analogy is often,
well it's like insulin to a diabetic.
It's the same thing.
And the more you challenge that you're
stigmatizing mental illness and how dare
you,
you know,
I've been accused.
Yeah,
I've been accused of shaming women,
which is of course the last,
you know,
all I care about is,
is empowering women around their health.
Literally I wake up every single day and
devote my life to that purpose.
Like the last thing I have any intention
of doing is shaming anyone who's made
this decision.
Well,
it's just whenever something make
someone uncomfortable with their
choices,
they immediately want to turn someone
else into a,
an aggressor or someone who is
victimizing them.
But this,
uh,
this woman that I'm friends with,
it's unfortunate because I feel like,
uh,
if she exercised,
at least she would know that she doesn't
exercise.
So if you don't exercise,
do you don't really know if that would
help.
Right.
You know,
but I hate to be that guy because I
already am,
you know,
like that proselytizing.
You got to work out.
God,
that's fucking annoying.
It's like the crossfit person or the
proselytizing Vegan or whatever,
a new cult member.
You just want to talk forever about it.
Still never going to convince someone
why people to hate you.
It's true.
And it's like the,
you know,
you bring a horse to water thing,
you can't,
can't make it happen of course.
But there is more.
Yeah.
Now,
um,
then I think ever before,
like people are ready and once they have
the information it's like,
you know,
usually like,
and then they just transferred.
Well,
these conversations are happening now
more and more with people,
um,
where they're starting to look at like,
what,
what is it in my life that's causing me
stress?
What is it in my life that is a
depleting my sleep patterns or my
health?
Have I ever gotten my blood test done
and find out where my nutrient levels
are?
Yes.
And you know,
and everybody's nutrient needs are very
different biologically.
People like people are going to respond
differently to drugs.
People are gonna respond differently to
food.
It's just we,
we come from different parts of the
world and some people need different
stuff.
And this is being called like an of one
medicine and meaning like meaning the
number of people in a study.
So like the phrases and of one medicine,
because we're beginning to understand
exactly what you're saying,
which is that it's you,
this is your thing.
This is your journey.
This is very specific to you,
right?
So like,
you know,
your depression let's say,
could be because you have a b,
12 deficiency.
It could be because you have low thyroid
function.
It could be because you're taking birth
control.
It could be because you know your dog
died.
It could be because you have a shitty
job that you hate.
It could be because your marriage has to
go.
And it could be because you're ready for
some psycho spiritual emergence,
you know,
and you are the only one who really
knows and who really can figure it out.
But we on the conventional side of
things,
seek to depersonalize it.
So it's,
it's not you,
it has nothing to do with you.
It's just a chemical process that's
unfolding and you need this one size
fits all intervention.
It's very disingenuous,
but it's also a super common.
Isn't that weird that that everyone,
I mean there's the access to the data is
there for everybody.
It's there for psychiatrists as well.
Like they would know the efficiency or
the effectiveness rather of exercise.
Right.
But that's what I'm saying.
It's really coming down to like almost
religious level belief systems.
Like either you believe,
right,
which I used to ps.
Either you believe that we're sort of
machines,
right?
Like as Alan Watts would say,
we're like flesh robots on a dead rock
floating in the middle of nowhere.
So everything is purposeless and random
and it's just bad luck and bad genes.
And you know,
it's like the other shoe could fall at
any moment and life is just the hustle
and you're just trying to survive and
you got to avail yourself of real
medicine,
which is pharmaceutical medicines.
The only legit option and you just got
to do it and you know what you want some
credit for even having the courage to
actually take the steps to take your
meds.
Right?
So that's one mindset.
And then the other,
which is I believe growing,
um,
is that we have no idea what we're doing
scientifically.
And we're just looking through the
keyhole.
And Science is a process.
It's not like a destination where the
science is settled.
My favorite phrase,
so you know,
the body itself has this,
you know,
chiropractors call it vitalism like has
this innate wisdom and it doesn't make
mistakes.
Like it doesn't mess up.
Every single thing your body is doing is
in wise response to a perceived,
you know,
stimulus,
right?
And Diseases of course,
cancer,
no,
no.
It would include without exception,
without an,
I could explain what I mean by that,
but,
right,
so,
so if I have an ache or a pain or I,
my hair's falling out or I have a tumor
growing out of the side of my body,
my first response it's possible could be
curiosity.
Like it could be,
what is this about,
you know,
where am I off?
Right?
Because in like indigenous cultures for
example,
illness is not like something that your
body is doing.
It's the,
you know,
sort of manifestation of things out of
balance with you and your soul,
you know,
with you and the relationships in your
life with you and nature and maybe the
collective itself.
So it's this expression,
it's this physical manifestation of
something much deeper that has roots.
And until you understand what those
roots are for you,
you won't resolve it.
Right?
Serious errors like birth defects and
things along those lines.
That's not like a wise response to
anything,
right?
It's an error.
It's a good question.
You know,
the,
the sort of like congenital question,
like if you're just like born without a
leg,
I mean you could take it to the extent
where you say,
okay,
so what drove the birth defect?
Whether it was some sort of,
you know,
okay,
so let's back up a second because Epi
genetics,
right?
Is the word de jure for beyond or above
actually technically jeans,
right?
So there's the genes are interesting,
but perhaps as insignificant as like 1%
of what makes us sick,
right?
Or well,
we never studied what makes us well it's
like a total black box.
But epigenetics is like how does the
environment impact our genes?
Right?
So you could argue that a lot of
congenital,
you know,
sort of malformations and things like
that because this was an area of study
for me when I was prescribing to
pregnant women,
which believe it or not,
was my specialty prescribing psychiatric
meds to two pregnant women.
Um,
that it is a risk in response to that
exposure.
And it's the body's method of adapting
to an exposure or is it just an error?
Like if someone's born without a leg,
what kind of adaptation is that?
It seems like so just some sort of a
genetic error.
No,
it depends how you want to look at it.
I mean,
to me there are no errors because the
body is responding to a perceived
stimulus.
Now if you throw a lot of toxicity,
you know,
in the way of your body,
there may be a limit to which a can or
will accommodate.
Right?
Cause like something confusing for me
was at one point I was reflecting on the
fact that,
you know,
we've had all of these environmental
exposures for like about a hundred
hundred and 50 years.
Like since the industrial revolution,
right?
So we like live totally different lives
now is all
these toxic exposures that we sit all
day and we don't sleep and we have
Monsanto and all the rest pretty much
for like the past 100 years or so.
We can adapt like my body is adapting
within the hours that were,
you know,
hanging out.
So why would it not have adapted over
the past 100 years?
And like a Paleo argument is like we've
evolves the same way for 95% of our
evolution and in now we just haven't
taken enough time to evolve to catch up
with today's modern influences.
Right.
But I actually think we're not meant to
accommodate this and we will self
extinguish.
Like if we don't course correct,
which I have faith we will do,
but we're not meant to adapt to this
kind of lifestyle.
Yeah,
exactly.
Chemicals,
you know of people if we don't course
correct,
I think we will.
And I think it's pretty much like,
I think even though we could
biologically adapt,
I think we won't because there is like a
cosmic intelligence that is holding us
accountable to a certain level of
respect for this human organism.
A certain level of respect for the
privilege of being alive.
You know?
And the way we're living today,
just like trashing ourselves and
trashing this planet is in,
is a violation.
So I dunno,
I just,
it's like a subtle point,
but I think the point is we're not going
to adapt,
so don't wait for it.
You know,
and we're just going to get sicker and
sicker and sicker and die and,
and perhaps that is the most intelligent
response.
Doom and gloom.
No,
I said it's going to get better.
Remember the sacrifice for productivity,
the daily sacrifice for productivity
that comes at the expense of health and
happiness is the norm.
You know,
that's what a lot of people deal with.
They deal with having bills and like as
you were pointing about,
pointing out about exorbitant medical
bills,
right?
I mean,
so many people that are in the medical
industry start their practice or start
practicing being a doctor of
professional doctor with a quarter
million dollar debt.
Right?
Which is crazy.
It's so much money.
It's so crazy.
It's so what a terrible idea.
Like what's almost mandatory for any
civilization?
Well,
you need health care for sure.
You need to be able to take care of
people.
I got an idea.
Let's take those people that you need to
make these critical decisions to save
your life and let's fuck them over.
Let's saddle those people up with crazy
debt and leave them trapped in a world
of stress.
And I got an even better idea when
they're going through the residency.
Let's not let them sleep.
Right?
Right.
Keeping caffeinated sugar and work and
give them pills.
Give them,
giving them amphetamines.
You know,
give him adderall.
You need a prescription,
sally,
are you tired Sally?
I got a little pick me up.
It's called adderall sweetie.
It's not your fault.
You've got Adhd,
d s t u P
qrs.
But that's how it's like a hazing.
It's a hazing process,
not unlike the military.
Right.
You know,
so that you remain loyal.
I mean,
that's obviously one perspective on it,
but this is what I'm saying,
right?
Like I was $200,000
in debt.
It took a lot for me to just like jump
ship and say,
okay,
whatever.
I,
you know,
invested that and I'm just going to walk
away from it.
Most people,
you know,
are not in a position to do that.
And perhaps that's part of the design.
I Dunno.
Well I don't,
even if it's not designed,
it's a very efficient,
efficient survival mechanism for the
industry.
You know,
it just seems like one of the worst ways
for someone to start a career in taking
care of people's,
to be all fucked up themselves,
but they need to be broken down in that
way to stay in line.
And that's kind of,
it's just basic,
you know,
sort of hierarchical systems work this
way.
There is no conspiracy or is it people
just taking advantage of this need and
being greedy and just charging
exorbitant amounts of money and having
the whole thing subsidized by the
government.
So that could be expensive.
And then the whole thing is crazy.
And also here's the big one that a lot
of people,
maybe if you're a kid,
you're not aware of this,
your student loans you til you're dead.
You cannot get out of those fuckers.
Like you can get out.
You could,
you could buy Ferrari,
you could be stupid and buy a Ferrari
and go God damn it,
I can't afford this car.
And you go bankrupt and they will allow
you to go bankrupt.
Right.
That's that.
That can happen.
You can have a business,
make terrible decisions,
lose all your money would go bankrupt
and literally be absolved of your debt
except your student loans.
That shit is into your DNA.
They keep you,
you have to pay that.
You have to,
it's crazy.
It's so nuts how much money it is when
you find out what the student loan
industry is in this country and how much
money children go,
oh,
you're a fucking child when you're 18
years old,
right?
So you make some ridiculous decision to
go to some school and you get some grant
or you get some sort of scholarship and
then the rest of it you're going to get
loans or whatever the hell your
situation is.
And then you get out of four years and
then you go and do your masters.
You go and do some graduate work.
Ah,
you're funds,
you're fucked,
you're so broke.
And then if you get out,
what are the odds?
You even get a job in your field.
You know,
you have to scramble to try to make some
money and then you have this never
ending pool of debt that you have to
suck a little bit out of every month.
It's like living for the oasis on the
horizon,
but that's what we do in this country.
You know?
We just are constantly waiting for it to
feel okay.
Constantly waiting to until we get
there.
We're not getting there.
I think that free education,
if it would be possible,
if it is possible to do it without
ruining the educational system,
if it's not already ruined,
if it is possible to do that,
it'd be like one of the best things we
could ever do for young people.
Just keep them from being saddled down
with some bullshit that you have to keep
with you for the rest of your life.
Say you like are handicapped out the
gate.
Yeah,
it's crazy and it also,
it inhibits any risk taking it.
You're going to have any chance like to
jump ship and try something new.
Like maybe you're doing something,
but all the while you have this idea of
God,
I thank think this is really what I'm
supposed to be doing.
I'm always thinking about it.
I got to take a chance,
but I have this fucking debt and the
only way to really pay this debt off is
if I enter into this same,
that's it.
Oh,
that's a really important point because
if you sort of look across dimensions
culturally,
they're all geared towards supporting a
certain kind of mindset and mentality,
which is productivity oriented,
which is,
you know,
capitalism and consumer supportive.
Um,
in terms of that,
you know,
sort of financial apparatus.
And so the things and elements,
you know,
like Graham Hancock has talked about
this,
you know,
the elements that are convenient to that
paradigm,
including psychiatric meds and even
alcohol on some level,
like these more sort of suppressive
consciousness,
suppressive tools are sanctioned.
Right.
But the things that would encourage risk
taking and courage,
creative expression and courage,
you know,
sort of consciousness expansion are
demonized her,
you know,
rendered illegal because they're
inconvenient to the paradigm,
I guess.
But honestly,
I think it's a victim of circumstance
more than anything.
When I,
I don't,
I'm not necessarily,
I believe that when the psychedelic act
of 1970 was put into play,
it was clearly put it into play because
they were trying to arrest people that
were in the civil rights movement and
the antiwar movement.
That's been proven.
It's been proven that there was a
collusion and that what they were trying
to do was make it so that they could go
after these people in the civil rights
movement go after these people that were
in the antiwar movement and they would
catch them for drugs and arrest them and
they would cripple these movements.
And this is all like documented,
real clear by the Nixon administration.
The reason why they passed that sweeping
psychedelics act of 1970 which covered a
lot of stuff that's not even
psychoactive.
They didn't even know what they're
doing.
And they miss some of the big ones.
They missed like five methoxy DMT,
which is more than most potent
psychedelic drugs.
Don't demand just a few years ago used
to be able to buy that shit online from
a chemical companies.
They would give you like a jug of it.
They could get a whole city high for a
month and you could go buy it with a
credit card.
Not that I know of anybody who did it.
And I certainly didn't.
And I definitely still still don't have
any of it.
But if I did,
it's not even illegal.
That's what's crazy.
It's like they made stuff that was like
a normal part of human use for thousands
and thousands of years that made it
highly illegal.
And they did it at a time when they were
trying to break down these people that
we're trying to change society.
Right?
So that was 1970 but along the way,
I think what's really happened is it
became a matter of financial risk.
Like marijuana is a big one,
like financial risk of the
pharmaceutical drug companies.
If they found out that there's so many
different things that marijuana get
help,
whether it is a people's appetite or
certain arthritic conditions,
or you can go down the list,
uh,
kids with epilepsy,
it's a huge factor on children with
autism,
especially edible marijuana,
all these different things,
all these different things that it
treats.
If that was made legal and people
started turning to that and exercise and
it'll a holistic approach,
it would cost the pharmaceutical
companies literally billions of dollars
a year.
So I think that's the big conspiracy.
I think it's a,
it's not really a paradigm consciousness
sort of a thing.
As much as it's a financial thing.
I don't think the people that don't
totally related,
but I don't think the people that are
suppressing it or even aware of the
effects.
I agree.
No,
I would just part of the master puppet
string puller.
It's,
it's like this organism that's just
moved only in one direction,
you know?
Yes.
Money toward,
yeah.
The same reason why also involved in
trying to keep these drugs illegal.
You have prison guard unions because
they want to keep their money coming in.
Do you have police unions?
I mean there's a lot of that where you
find lobbying by these unlikely groups
and you're like,
I don't understand why,
and then you go,
oh,
they just want to make more money.
Right?
Like they're more than willing to lock
people up.
They're more than willing to demonize
helpful things that grow naturally and
have virtually no negative effects in
terms of like your health,
things like marijuana.
Totally.
I mean that's,
that's why I,
you know,
when I speak about this,
because I used to be really in like
warrior mode on this,
um,
topic.
Huh?
How so?
Like,
what do you mean by warrior?
I just thought,
okay.
Like I've,
you know,
once I woke up,
whatever it was almost 10 years ago.
Do you ever use Hashtag woke,
do you have a right to and no.
No.
Okay.
Should I know it's a joke with the kids
today.
Hashtag woke or Hashtag woke AAF.
I'm old.
I'm old too.
Okay.
Half that's good.
Woke as fuck.
Yeah.
Thanks.
I got that.
I'm a quick study.
So when you,
when you became aware of what I became
aware,
I was pissed.
What was,
was it a gradual process?
No,
no.
I um,
I would,
I got like sick,
I guess.
Uh,
wasn't very dramatic.
But my big sob story is that I was
diagnosed with my,
my first health condition,
which is an autoimmune disorder after my
first pregnancy.
Hashimoto's.
Oh,
I have the,
really?
Yes.
Oh,
that's interesting.
My Dad and my brother do.
My mom has it also,
I would just like not as common in men,
but probably because nobody's looking
for it.
Um,
yeah.
So I was diagnosed with that and I just
had this intuitive sense that I wasn't
going to go to a conventional doctor
even though I had never ever,
you know,
done anything but dismiss alternative
medicine.
Like I was hard core into the
pharmaceutical model,
very into science it from that
perspective.
Right.
And so I,
um,
but I knew that all they had to offer
was,
and I,
I
had enough patients that never felt well
on it.
And so it's weird stuff.
Yeah.
Stuff for a while.
And then I switched to armour thyroid
and a,
that's one reason why I got pissed at
doctor drew when doctor drew was giving
that,
um,
uh,
when he was talking about Hillary
Clinton and all of her health issues and
he was going over her prescription,
he was mocking the fact that she was on
armour thyroid and he was saying that
that's old.
That's an old way of treating him.
Like he doesn't know what the fuck he's
talking about.
He's absolutely wrong because I went
through a bunch of different stuff and
then when I took armor,
thyroid,
all of the symptoms went away.
Gone.
And that's what the data shows that
people feel subjectively better on t
three containing.
Yeah.
We'll explain what that is.
It comes from pig thyroid.
Yeah.
It's a glandular and he's not wrong
because it is an old fashioned medicine
wrong there.
It's ineffective though.
He was talking about how outdated it is
and that subject at all.
People feel better on it.
Yeah.
So I took that for something similar,
um,
called nature throid for a while.
But I went to a naturopath because,
which is so funny that I did that,
you know,
at that time it sounds like a hippie.
Did you go to a place with like macrame
and stuff?
Now?
It's really good friends.
Do you have any friends?
Very friendly.
Oh,
she's friendly.
Yeah.
Did she smell like,
but truly or incense?
Yes.
Oh,
she did.
Absolutely.
That was good.
That's,
that's it felt right.
Even that really struggling wrong at the
moment.
No I did.
And um,
she,
I put it into remission in the space of
like a year in my antibodies were like
in the high two thousands,
my Tsh was like 20 and I had to do to
put it in remission.
So the same things I do with my
patients.
So I initially just changed my diet.
So initially I just very simply at her
recommendation and I'm Italian.
I grew up Italian,
my mom's from Italy and I ate cheese and
bread of some variety,
like five times a day,
literally for my whole life.
Right.
So the two things,
of course she asked me to take out where
gluten and dairy,
dammit.
So has it been,
it was a very amazing transition,
but I,
my early,
when was that?
I started like pooping every day and
hadn't ever done that in my whole life.
Thank you.
These things that matter.
And so I was like,
wow,
she must be on to something.
And then later I layered in other
stuff.
Yeah.
Well you eating a lot of vegetables at
the time.
No,
I think it was more about what I took
out then at that point then like what I
put in.
But when I saw the change on paper,
I was like,
this is not even supposed to be
possible.
This is literally not even,
we're not even taught that this is
possible,
let alone that it has anything.
You know,
they're putting autoimmune conditions
into remission,
has anything to do with diet.
Right.
And so I was really indignant and I've
always been a science nut.
I've always spent Saturday,
you know,
like a good four hours every Saturday on
pub med.
Of course I'm looking at different stuff
over time,
but I went to pub med and I was like,
what else did I learn?
And I was like on an obsessive rampage
for like a good couple of years and
that's when I just turned over every
stone.
Like everything,
every sacred cow,
whether all these meds we were talking
about like you know,
statens or acid blockers are
antibiotics.
I then I got onto psych meds and then I
started to look at the science
supporting a very different kind of
perspective on,
you know,
this interconnected model and the gut
microbiome and you know,
sort of the impact of belief on our
biology that we can sort of like
reprogram our hardware with our
software,
which is like we're the only species
that can really do that.
Um,
that we can literally change.
Yeah,
exactly.
And,
but also interacts with your body and
then you change your body.
You literally change your body.
So what did you do to do that?
Like what methods?
So I was very reluctant to meditate.
I was an atheist,
my whole like a belligerent,
you know,
sort of like Dawkins level,
atheist,
um,
my whole life because I was a science
worshiper and I was like,
well,
you know,
spirituality and religion is for weak
people who like need to believe in some
fairytale to make them feel better about
typical New Yorker,
New York liberal coming at Ya,
New York liberals.
Scientists.
Exactly.
Well,
it's scientism,
right?
It literally is the Church of,
of science.
And so,
you know,
when I had this crisis of faith,
so to speak,
like I was lost for a long time because
science had sort of,
you know,
or what I believed has sort of failed me
in some ways and then I didn't have,
I don't know what the readiness to start
meditating or find out what you know
people were talking about when it comes
to spirituality.
Although I followed the literature,
so like I read the literature on
meditation and epigenetic expression for
years and years and years and I used to
tell my patients to do it,
but I didn't do it and hold you back
because I liked feeling stressed out.
Yeah.
When you don't do something,
you're not doing it because you like
actually being sick.
You like how you're feeling,
you're invested in it.
Is it that you like or that your
addictive familiar in that?
Yeah,
it's comfortable
and the unknown for some of my patients,
the meditation piece is the last part
because they know it's going to be the
game changer and they're not ready for
everything to just be totally
reconfigured.
They're not ready for that level of
transformation.
What they say too about sometimes people
that are addicted to cigarettes that
you're almost addicted to the idea that
you're doing something bad or yourself.
You're addicted to that rush of being
naughty.
Yeah.
Oh,
so good.
It confirms,
yeah,
some like self loathing hook too because
you're like,
fuck it.
I'm alive.
Who gives a shit?
This is all bullshit.
I'm not the future.
Fuck the future.
Trialists settle now.
Right?
Like so many fucking smart people smoke
cigarettes and it's so confusing.
It's like you're making a deal to slowly
pay to poison.
You'll like throwing a little bit of
money in the pot every month.
Guarantee you guaranteeing that 20 years
down a line,
30 years down the line,
however long it takes,
you're going to have some,
some bolt is going to come off the
machinery and the,
Hey Mike,
you got a tumor in your lungs.
It's not good.
We're going to have to cut one of these
things out of your chest.
You can get by on one lung buddy.
This is what we got to do though.
We got to,
you got to start eating papayas.
Like what sort of thing,
why am I even alive?
You know,
we all do stuff like that.
I mean it's not always trained,
but we recognize,
right?
Yeah,
we do because we,
you know,
we're invested in reflecting a felt
wrongness,
you know,
I would call it felt wrong.
Like we feel deep inside something is
wrong,
wrong with us,
wrong with society,
right.
Something's missing and then we don't
want to pretend that everything is okay.
So we self medicate,
you know,
right there with you know,
drugs or cigarettes or you know,
workaholism or you know,
sex addiction or we're all sort of in
this place not wanting to acknowledge
that there's a reason,
you know,
like one of my favorite quotes is this,
like Christian Murti quote,
that it's no measure of health to be
well adapted to a profoundly sick
society.
Right.
So,
right.
We really low.
I love New York.
It's the best.
I love the traffic.
I like.
You're like,
oh,
you're a sick person,
man.
Nigga is wrong with you.
Totally love it.
Hong Kong some home.
Yeah.
That's a weird,
one of my very,
very best friends is just addicted to
York.
Yeah.
And it's like loves it.
He's been there forever.
He's like an abusive relationship.
Loves the city.
Totally.
But he loves the energy.
He likes to all the cars and traffic.
I don't,
you know,
I don't know what it is,
but he's healthy like fairly like
physically he's got a few issues but
like mentally
very healthy.
That's unusual.
Look like just one thing sorted out.
He's a smart guy.
It's problematic.
He just loves the,
I don't know what it is.
Hong Kong,
you know
that's the thing though.
Like if you've,
if you think about what the messaging is
from the top down we were talking about,
right?
Like the messaging is keep it together.
Punch the clock on Monday,
like you know,
sorted out right.
And you're supposed to be like fine,
be fine.
Right.
But many of us don't feel fine.
No like range,
a huge range of not fineness.
That's what I'm saying when I say like a
felt wrongness and that's actually
healthy,
you know,
to sense that.
And a lot of artists I would say are the
canaries in the coal mine,
so to speak.
Like they're the ones who feel,
you know,
the,
the collective wound,
you know,
if you want to call it that more than we
do,
they're sensitive in ways.
Well,
I don't want to put you in my category,
it's more of an artist than I am.
I'm not an artist.
So I sort of look at yourself as an
artist.
No,
no,
definitely not.
No.
It's interesting actually because most
of my patients are real or they become
after I get them off meds.
Yeah,
Whoa,
wait a minute.
Yeah.
So they weren't artists.
You get them off meds and all of a
sudden they start like composing music
or something or making paintings are
exactly,
they say find some repressed expression,
something like that,
you know.
But if you also look at,
you know,
like I just wrote an article recently
that tied in Chris Cornell and his
hurts.
I know,
I know.
Bothered me.
And it's,
it's not an isolated,
I mean,
listen,
I don't know the details.
I don't know what happened,
but I said she likes the smell a rat.
Yeah.
Let's just say what his wife believes
that they sent his wife.
He took too many antidepressants or anti
anxiety medications,
but wasn't there like some rumor about
him having a relapse?
Was there a rumor,
rumor that there was like track marks,
fresh track marks,
CV,
find anything on that?
How the hell would anybody know that
that seems like some shit that people
just start making up the annual listen
and I could be accused of doing the same
thing,
even commenting,
but his wife who is married to him was
the one that said that she believed,
like when she talked to him on the phone
that he had taken too much of his anti
anxiety medication and it'd be one thing
to just be like,
oh,
she's like a grieving widow.
If there wasn't like a very indicting
body of evidence that unequivocally like
literally two new studies just came out
this week that unequivocally implicate
benzodiazepines in homicide and suicide.
Right.
So you are the very important finish
study demonstrated that benzodiazepines
are led to like a 223% increase risk of
committing homicide.
Jesus Christ,
they,
um,
along with the antidepressants and
actually other psychotropics including
stimulants.
You know,
all of these medications have been
linked to an increase in suicide as
well.
So when I hear about a school shooting
or I hear about the German wings,
you know,
plane crash wings,
that Guy Lubick like who,
who took down the plane,
the German wings plane,
he suicided with a whole plane of people
and crashed the plane.
Like when I hear about these mass
murder,
like menace to society kind of
situations,
my first thought is what psych meds were
they on?
And you know,
my training basically conditioned me to
say,
oh well they're mentally ill.
So obviously they're taking psych meds.
That's like saying umbrellas cause the
rain,
right?
That's not how it works.
Causation.
Correlation.
Exactly.
But actually there's a massive
suppressed body of literature that
implicates these medications,
all of them.
And we know why we think,
right.
So we think that it has to do with the
way you metabolize some people
metabolize these medications.
So they,
you might be born with a genetic variant
in your liver,
then makes it so that you buy design,
metabolize medications differently than
someone else.
Right?
So you can enter into a state of
what's called auto intoxication more
easily than someone else,
even sometimes in a couple of doses.
And you develop what's called Aca
Athenia induced impulsivity,
impulsivity,
which is like ack.
Athena is like this feeling like you
just want to crawl under your skin,
but you seem really chill.
It's really creepy,
like horror movie level.
Um,
to fucking boil over.
Exactly right.
I had a,
I spoke in July in London.
I did this like workshop and this guy
contacted me named David Carmichael and
he's like,
I'd love to meet you,
followed your work and I want us to tell
you about my story.
Um,
I had known about this paper of which he
was one of 11,
10 or 11 subjects,
um,
by these authors.
Lucier and karate was from 2011 older
paper where they took all these people
who had committed like heinous acts,
right?
Like,
you know,
murdered their therapists,
are killed,
their child or themselves jumped in
front of a train or whatever.
And they were prescribed antidepressants
for totally run of the mill stress.
Right?
So like work stress or a dog dying,
not because they had like severe mental
illness and we're suicidal,
right?
These people were not suicidal.
They were not homicidal.
They were normal citizens and they went
on to do this crazy thing.
And what they found was when they
analyze each of these,
you know,
victims,
perpetrators,
everyone to look at it,
um,
they found,
they all had these liver variants that
I'm talking about so that they were
basically poisoned by medication,
but before they were poisoned,
they were put into this altered state
where they did impulsive leave,
violent things.
So this guy basically gets on the stage
where I was speaking and he talks about
how he was prescribed Paxil,
uh,
because he works,
I think as an accountant.
Um,
and he was prescribed it for work
related stress.
Like it was just like taking on too much
stress at work.
Right.
And he remembers feeling like his mind
like slip away.
Like he began,
you entered this realm of like psychosis
essentially.
And he started to,
you know,
to develop all of these paranoid
beliefs.
But he looked and people told him like,
Oh,
you're getting better.
I'm so glad you're feeling better.
Long Story Short,
he strangled his 11 year old son dead.
And that's before or after you met him
after,
this was actually years ago and he was
not jailed at him and he was telling you
about all this.
And then after that he killed his kid.
No,
he killed his son before we met years
ago.
But he wanted,
you know,
to share,
with the,
the audience of doctors I was speaking
to like,
listen,
it's Russian based on this medicated,
which is rare actually believe it or not
because a lot of times these people are
jailed.
So it's like,
you know,
punishing the,
punishing the victim so to speak.
But that's sort of the issue that it's
an important issue.
Right.
Cause your friend.
Okay.
So let's say some people,
this is in line with their consciousness
to,
to not have any curiosity about why
they're having symptoms,
not want to see what they can do in
terms of optimizing their lifestyle.
It's just like not their deal.
Right?
Right.
So they want to take a medication and
they want to suppress their symptoms and
just like,
hope it works out.
That's fine.
I don't care what people do.
This should be a free country,
right?
You do what you want to do and practice
the medicine that makes sense to you.
But the sort of like chink in the armor
is perhaps this issue,
which is that we don't really have a
good way of identifying,
you know,
it's Russian roulette.
We don't have a good way of identifying
if you're going to be David Carmichael,
right?
So,
and it's,
you know,
it's one thing to kill yourself
impulsively,
but like,
you know,
those school shootings,
for example,
have without an exception,
been committed by,
uh,
people who are kids who are recently
medicated.
So
just as a public health issue or coming
off psych meds.
Exactly.
The changes.
Yes.
If not 100% is really crazy that that's
tonight.
And when you bring that up,
by the way,
people call you a gun rights apologist.
Well you're,
you're distorting the issue,
you're turning it to a psych meds issue.
When it's a gun issue.
If these people don't have guns,
they can't commit these crimes.
Like that to me is a very bizarre way of
looking at like the one science,
which is why would they,
but it's,
it's what you were talking about before
where psychiatrists aren't talking about
this,
this is,
this is such a taboo subject that by the
time it gets to the average educated and
informed person who for the most part it
was probably liberal and you know,
you're,
cause we're talking about people that
want to get rid of guns with what
they're seeing is only the gun.
They're not seeing the mindset behind
the ability to do something like that,
which is relevant context.
This liver issue that you're talking
about is this testable and nobody tests
for it.
Oh Jesus.
Clearly apart from functional medicine
doctors
perhaps,
but for the most part,
they're not going to be the one starting
patients on psychiatric meds.
Most psych meds are started by primary
care doctors after 10 minutes.
And there's a scientific consensus that
this issue exists that this with this
liver issue that if you take these
medications,
it can turn turn you into this or take
you to the psychotic state.
Yes,
yes.
And you would be surprised how much
scientific acknowledgement there is of
such quality,
again,
I'm sorry.
Or
it's called Eq Athenia induced
impulsivity.
Achalasia is the,
um,
experience,
the symptom neurologic symptom that's
induced by the impaired,
it's thought to be impaired metabolism
on the liver level of these medications.
Um,
so this is not like a theory,
it's not a theory.
It's,
yeah,
but there's a lot of stuff like that.
Like there's,
um,
you know,
in the literature there's something
called antidepressant,
um,
tacky phylaxis,
which is the acknowledgement in the
scientific literature that like a good
30% of the time they just stopped having
an effect.
Like stop working.
Yeah.
That's the thing that people that I know
that have taken the most sad that the
doctor will tell you,
hey,
this is going to work for a little while
and then it's not going to work anymore.
Just hope you don't like.
Well my friend who got on them,
and actually I have two friends that got
a great benefit from getting on ssrs.
They had a great benefit and they both
eventually got off of them.
Cool.
They got on them and then their life
improved.
They improve the,
the just the overall existence that they
experience,
like they improve their job,
they improve their,
just their state,
their status in life,
relationship stuff.
All these different things improved and
then they slowly wean themselves off and
now they don't need them anymore.
But both of my friends that were on them
say that it was a great benefit of that
to get on them.
So that's a rare story.
I would say it's a pretty rare story.
Now you could argue that I have a skewed
exposure to the population because I
only see the people who've been on 10 20
years and want to desperately get off
and can't,
you know,
but I am again,
this public health issue aside,
which is that,
you know,
these medications could be inducing
impulsive violence at random and like
perhaps we should at least be talking
about this as a society,
right?
Right.
That issue aside,
I'm,
you know,
a crusader for informed consent.
I believe that you just should know all
the options and all of the available
science and then you make your own damn
decision,
right?
With your free will.
You do what's right for you,
what matches your level of
consciousness,
right?
Because the problem is that most people
are not taken off of meds.
Um,
and they are maintained for longterm,
even though all of the longterm science
suggest that people do worse longterm on
all categories of psychiatric beds than
if they were never medicated.
And this includes this anti psychotics
for schizophrenia,
all of them,
all of them.
And the person who exposed this and
really,
you know,
sort of blew the whistle on this issue.
His book changed my life and made me put
down my prescription pad is um,
Robert Whittaker who's an investigative
journalist and he wrote a book called
Anatomy of an epidemic.
And I've read it,
you know,
when it came out and I was ready to read
it because and receive it cause I just
had this health experience in my own
right.
So I read it and basically what he says
is,
okay,
so we have escalating rates of
treatment,
right?
Like more and more people,
you know,
16% of the American population is on
these meds.
Right?
Good on a lot of your friends,
my friends and with more treatment,
shouldn't we have less disability?
Right?
Like shouldn't people be more functional
and less sick?
And what we find is that the reverse is
true.
You know,
that we have more disability with more
medicating.
So his book goes through all of these
studies.
I never heard about one of them in my
ivy league training.
All of these studies that are not
industry funded,
right?
Because we know that the pharmaceutical
industry is four times more likely to
publish something.
Um,
when it's positive then when it's not
and they can publish whatever they want
and not publish whatever they don't
want.
Right.
So they are in charge of their own
policing,
which is the Fox guarding the hen house
kind of a situation.
Um,
so these were all non industry funded
studies and the story they tell is quite
different than what you might imagine.
And it's,
it's like almost shocking,
right?
That you have schizophrenia,
Obviously you need to take meds,
right?
Right.
Well,
but what if like doing something is not
as good as doing nothing according to
the published literature,
right?
So doing nothing is better according to
the published literature then doing
something than doing medications.
So taking medication for site,
some sort of a psychotic disorder.
What,
what are the odds that it's going to
work?
So when we're looking at the data that
suggests that it's effective to take an
anti psychotic there without exception
short term studies.
So six to eight weeks.
Oh.
But people are taking these medications
for months to years and they lose their
efficiency over time.
Where their effectiveness or dating
effects usually upfront.
Not the same as us.
The sorrows in terms of,
no,
the story is similar because if we look
at our outcomes and long term like,
like do you have a job?
You know,
do you have a friend network you like,
are you a functional member of society?
If we look at those parameters in the
longterm,
people do worse.
And that's his argument,
you know,
is that,
that's why we have more and more of the
population literally getting checks from
the government because they cannot
function in society even though they're
medicated to the hilt,
you know,
like they're fully treated,
so to speak.
And he makes this argument for
Benzodiazepines,
for stimulants.
And if you look into the literature,
you understand that all that's happening
is you're forcing an adaptation on the
part of the body.
This is a chemical,
it is not fixing anything and just like
alcohol.
Okay?
Like some people love alcohols.
For some people it's very relaxing,
right?
Some people hate it and it's terrible
and it makes them sick.
So just like any other chemical
substance with unpredictably
psychoactive effects,
it may be adaptive for a given period of
time.
But we know through the alcohol analogy
that there's no free lunch,
right?
So even if it's adaptive in the short
term,
your body adapts habituates you become
potentially dependent,
although that's a more complex
conversation.
You know what drives that dependency.
But the longterm is known to us like the
long term picture of like chronic use of
alcohol for let's say social anxiety.
It doesn't look pretty if you want to
just stop drinking 15 years down the
line after you've been drinking every
right.
So,
but we've been told to think of psych
meds differently and when I'm trying to
say is we shouldn't be right because
they are just chemicals having chemical
effects that your body is adapting to.
So obviously that chemical effect is not
going to endure that.
Like it's not going to last.
And then there's going to be a cost.
So one of the major pieces of informed
consent I would like to see foregrounded
for people is it may be nearly
physically impossible for you to come
off of this medication after several
years of use.
Are you cool with that?
Right?
Like are you physically impossible and
all you have to do is google like
antidepressant withdrawal or
benzodiazepine withdrawal,
right?
Cause we're keeping people on these meds
longterm.
Cause of course we're not fixing the
root cause of the problem,
right?
It's like if you have glass in your
foot,
we're not taking the glass out.
We're just like putting a bandaid on it,
giving you a tylenol and being like,
okay get out of here.
You know,
so we're not fixing the problem so to
speak.
So we're masking it and there's going to
be,
you know,
sort of it's going to,
it's like a whack.
Like is this going to keep manifesting
in other ways?
So people are kept on these meds
longterm and then coming off them is,
I've come to the conclusion that they're
more habit forming than any chemicals on
the planet.
Crack Oxi content,
nothing.
They,
they do not.
Hold a candle to how hard it can be to
come off of psych meds.
All you need to do is ask someone.
So your friends are very rare examples
because there are millions of people on
the Internet right now trying to help
each other like survive the process of
coming physically survive,
let alone,
you know,
psycho spiritually survive the process
of coming off of meds.
So that's what I focus on.
You know,
in my day to day practice now.
No.
Are there certain meds that are more
difficult to come off than others?
I would say yes,
although I've seen exceptions to that
too.
You know,
I would say that there are certain
antidepressants that are notoriously
challenging,
you know,
meds like Paxil or affects her.
But then Prozac,
which is supposed to be like have this
long half life and be easy to come off
of.
And I have patients who develop what
looks like aids.
Like they get so sick in such
complicated ways that no one believes
them and then they think that they're,
you know,
well you must have ms or you must have,
Mano or you must have,
you know,
some new diagnosis.
And in the literature since 2014 has
told us,
no,
this is a withdrawal is,
is a complicated protracted withdrawal
that is worse than any other meds out
there.
And so if you knew that,
you might be like,
all right,
well what are my other options?
Do I have other options?
And you know,
since I put down my prescription,
I have many years now of experience of
treating all manner of bipolar disorder,
suicidality and psychosis without
medication.
And let me tell you like the outcomes
that I get today,
I couldn't have fantasized about when I
was prescribing.
I didn't even know that this was
possible.
So if you know that these outcomes are
possible,
then maybe you would consider a
lifestyle approach.
But you have to know it's possible.
That's informed consent.
Best case scenario.
When you were prescribing and d,
what did it ever feel like?
Like what I mean did,
did,
did it ever get to the point where you
were wondering like,
the none of none of these people are
really getting better.
They're,
they're improving in certain ways where
they're not getting better.
You don't have to the goal of getting
them totally better.
What was your goal?
Management Management.
So the idea is you have an issue.
This issue has never gone away.
Let's just throw a wet blanket on the
soccer.
Yeah.
See if we could,
uh,
hold down the fire.
Exactly.
And you know what,
I have a lot of compassion.
I've,
many of my friends are conventional
psychiatrist,
so I have compassion for people who are
in the trenches practicing conventional
approaches because I thought I was doing
good.
You know,
when I was prescribing I thought I was
doing good things for these.
Yeah.
These friends,
uh,
how do they feel about what you're doing
now?
They sort of like tolerate me.
I don't know.
Well,
it's funny because,
because I have this,
I don't know what you want to call it,
like scientific advantage,
meaning like,
I,
I know more of the literature,
I've read more of it.
I've obsessive Lee devoted my life to
this subject.
They know sort of not to fuck with me on
some level.
Like,
so I have respect.
Um,
but they also,
it's like my thing that I do over here,
we have a business,
my business given pills.
Crazy people like leave me alone.
Yeah,
exactly.
I share an office,
one of my best friends,
you know,
he rents from my office,
with all the Buddhas everywhere.
And I mean,
he's very,
he's more conscious about it.
Then the,
actually,
he works in forensics.
Um,
which means that he works to sort of
identify where people in the legal
system are being medicated necessarily
or unnecessarily.
So.
Yeah,
there's all sorts of weird
specializations within the guild of
psychiatry.
It's like a many tentacled animal.
So when you say management,
like did you ever take someone from
being like a real mess and bring them
off the ledge and then their life
improved?
Um,
yes,
that is,
that's the good summary of,
of what I do today.
So I see the sickest people that no one
can help because they've gotten to the
end of the road.
So they've done electroconvulsive
therapy,
they're on six medications,
they've been hospitalized,
even in state facilities there,
you know,
at the end of their rope because they're
not well.
And even conventional psychiatry has
nothing left to offer them.
So I,
you know,
people think like,
oh,
I treat the worried well like some upper
east side,
you know,
woman who's having an affair and she's
stressed out or whatever it's called,
the worried well,
yeah,
but it's not,
you know,
it's not true.
Like my patients are very sick and you
know,
I have an online version of what I do in
the office and the outcomes there are
even wilder,
the ones in my office.
So you can even do this totally on your
own.
It's not like some Voodoo,
I'm working on Madison Avenue in New
York,
but like for example,
okay so one of my,
so I've started to video interview these
people as social proof and like it's all
about my website and you can see what
they have to say about it because why
would you believe me?
Cause it sounds crazy what I'm saying.
So like,
so say I come to you and I say,
Hey,
I've got real problems across all Tommy
Brown,
super bummed out.
Can't keep it together.
99 problems.
So this I'll tell you about a woman,
allie.
Okay,
so she a real name?
No,
she's a,
she's on my website and a video.
Yeah.
That she's done.
She is an intrepid woman.
She's an incredible,
some beloved.
Um,
I've never said that about a person
during trepid.
She is,
that's the point I'm ultimately going to
make is that this process of moving
through the fire of your mental illness,
which I don't believe in mental illness,
but moving through the fire.
I don't,
what do you believe?
I believe that we are by design as
humans.
Yeah.
You know that we feel things intensely
and some people have experiences,
you know,
like in other cultural settings,
some of the early experiences as what we
would label schizophrenia.
You know,
there is an elder that is assigned to
you to,
to shepherd you through your psycho
spiritual emergence.
You know,
we just don't have a cultural context
for anything other than full and total
complacency,
full and total adaptation to this sick
society.
Right?
So just
godless of environmental influences and
whatever genetic problems you might
have,
people can have something really wrong
with their mind.
Right.
I don't ever think it's really wrong
when it gets really wrong,
is under the influence of Psych meds
always.
So there's very few exceptions.
If someone's experiencing psychotic
breaks and they don't get put on psych
medication,
does it go away?
I mean that's what the longterm data I
was describing for you.
It does.
So we have turned what might've been a
single episode experience that when
properly supported for totally
completely resolves and you get back to
life,
which is what used to happen even in the
early 19 hundreds,
you know,
when we documented the natural history,
so to speak,
of these illnesses,
we would see that they would go away on
their own within a year,
you know,
80% of it.
So when they would come up out of
nowhere,
they would go away out of nowhere as
well.
Right?
Huh.
And we've turned them how many people
you're talking about Aussies,
sorry to interrupt you,
but like what,
how big is this study?
Like how many people are being many,
many.
And this is where whittaker is like,
you know,
my knight in shining armor,
Robert Winter Guard,
because he's cataloged all of this data.
It's,
there's a robust amount of data and
importantly it wasn't paid for by the
industry.
So that's an important bias to control
for.
Right?
So if someone comes to you and they're
psychotic,
so,
so something to tell you about Allie.
Right.
Okay.
Um,
and her video is on my website.
This is all you know,
fully with her consent that I share it
and she came to me end of her rope.
She came with her husband from Kansas to
my office and she was actively,
you know,
in an episode.
What are her episodes?
Okay.
Her episodes are three days before her
period for years she would develop
psychotic symptoms,
become totally paranoid and delusional
to the extent that at one point she was
digging a hole in her face trying to get
at like a thread she thought was in
there.
She committed,
attempted to commit suicide multiple
times.
She had been on at least seven different
psychiatric medications in and out of
hospitals,
like a laundry list of diagnoses like
this literally including bipolar
disorder with psychotic features,
premenstrual dysphoric disorder,
you know,
all manner of dating back from like
eating disorders.
In her earlier history she'd been
through the ringer.
Okay.
So she was like a professional psych
patient and I was the last stop before
an inpatient facility.
Basically like institutionalization.
Okay.
I told her this is how it's going to go.
So I have like a very heavy hand upfront
and I can be a hard ass for sure.
Um,
but it's in service of passing the baton
to these women because I don't have
longterm patients.
Like there's an intense window and then
they,
they're done with me right.
Once they're through the birth canal so
to speak.
Right.
So what I asked her to do is follow a
very strict diet,
no cheating,
none like zero bullshit.
Okay.
So what's the Diet?
Okay,
so the template for the Diet that I
recommend is based not only on like my
personal experience,
but also on my work with my mentor Dr.
Nicholas Gonzalez,
who was the most best figure in modern
medicine.
He passed suddenly in 2015 but he for 27
years treated terminal cancer,
metastatic like no hope,
cancer,
literally,
um,
neurodegenerative illnesses,
lyme disease,
you know,
diabetes all with a 100% holistic
approach that was based on three
pillars,
a personalized diet.
So like one of 10 diets,
um,
coffee enemas.
Oh,
do you know that?
If you heard of it,
right?
Cause it's like in the Zeitgeists like
people are hearing about coffee enemas.
Coffee.
Yeah.
I know it's only necessary because we
live in like a pretty toxic world at
this point.
But what happens is the caffeine,
okay,
so you're sticking this little tube like
12 inches of the,
actually I know and it seems totally
crazy and weird,
but you do it all yourself.
You don't go somewhere to do it.
It's not like that.
And you're hitting this like it's called
a flexor.
You're hitting this point right here
where your intestines come across and
then down.
Okay.
And right there is a nerve bundle.
That reflex is to your,
it's called a parasympathetic nerve
bundle.
It reflexes to your liver and it
basically helps your liver to dump
toxicants.
Like it's,
it's a,
it's like a supercharging of your livers
ability to detox you.
Right.
Coffee in there because the caffeine
stimulates that nerve bundle.
It's basically like jacking up your
liver.
It cause we don't know how to detox
better than our own body does.
Your liver is charged with that
responsibility.
So if you can help your liver do it,
it's going to be best.
And,
and this is most relevant in cancer,
like radical cancer treatments because
when the tumors are breaking down,
you need to flush that waste or you'll
die.
Like literally it's called Tumor Lysis
Syndrome.
So you know,
some early pioneers discover that coffee
enemas are critical,
like literally life or death critical
for helping you flush those wastes.
So I learned about them from the master
and since using them in my practice
completely changed my practice.
So like a med taper that would take two
to three years now takes me like six
months was a given patient and,
and Allie,
so,
so allie started doing coffee enemas
twice a day.
So,
but the dietary template is,
is a little bit,
I wouldn't say it's like totally,
um,
uh,
people think healthy,
right?
And they think like Vegan or they think
vegetarian or they think,
you know,
tons of green juice or whatever.
And I noticed early on that as long as
my patients say to fair amount of red
meat,
they got better.
And I used to be like an ethical
vegetarian when I was eating like cheese
doodles and Pepsi basically and so it
was very confusing to me that you know,
red meat could be a healthy part of
anyone's lifestyle or you know anything
I could ever wrap my mind around
recommending.
But over the past 10 years and now with
the understanding of Nick's metric,
you know where there are some people who
do require red meat to balance their
nervous system,
essential
actual requirement or is this,
can this be mitigated through like a
very smart and conscious vegetarian
diet?
Like if you're really careful about your
nutrients and making sure they get the
essential fatty acids and making sure
you get the essential amino acids and a
really balanced profile of vegetable
protein.
It's a great question.
Ultimately my goal in this month is to
clear the slate,
right?
Of all the stuff that's like yanking on
your brain and your immune system and
driving inflammation so that you can
begin to sense what you need.
Has He,
have you ever had anybody that attempted
to do it was so like hemp protein or pea
protein or a vegetable based proteins
point.
I am going for gold.
Right.
So I'm interested in like massive
transformation for people and not just
like,
oh I guess I feel a little better so I
won't even see a new patient if they're
not willing to at least try for the
month to eat red meat.
Really,
I'm still a little,
so it's all just like what you've
experienced for working with patients.
But if you ever experienced a single
patient that tried to do it correctly
through vegetable protein,
the job at mount,
try it.
I wouldn't cause I,
you know what I'm saying like,
but I do have this online program where
there are people who get well on and
they stick to a vegetarian diet.
So it's apparently possible turn it when
she can get eggs.
You know in his model there were no
vegan diets and it's based on the work
of Weston price.
You know he is Weston price.
Yeah.
He's like a dentist in the 19 hundreds
who like went around the world with his
wife and studied all of these different
people who like indigenous people all
over like Eskimos,
like Himalayan,
you know,
folks,
Mexican folks in South American and
studied the healthy indigenous
populations that we're not eating
industrialized food.
Right.
And what he found was they all eight
different stuff.
So there isn't like a diet,
right?
So how do you know,
what is your version?
Right?
So like an Eskimo doesn't eat coconuts
and like a mess.
I warrior doesn't eat whale blubber.
So like,
how do you know what's your version?
The truth is only,
you know,
but like our signals are so distorted
and suppress that we can't figure it
out.
But you'll begin to like clear the,
like lower the white noise enough if you
have this month long experience of
detox.
So I asked,
I asked for daily meditation,
three minutes,
um,
I told you I'm going to Kundalini
zealot.
So I asked for people to do that before
the podcast.
Yeah.
Okay.
They didn't hear me.
Yeah.
So,
so I,
I came to Kundalini Yoga basically out
of sheer desperation at a very difficult
time in my life after my,
largely after my mentor died.
And it totally changed my,
like rewired my nervous system,
literally,
literally where now nothing stresses me
out.
But if you have someone,
I mean obviously not a Vegan,
but if you have someone that comes to
that does not want to eat meat but wants
to try this out and wants to try this
out with a,
I mean,
it's really just the science of
nutrition.
I mean,
you can eat a vegan diet and be healthy
as long as you do it right.
Well,
so his model is that there are different
kinds of people and different kinds of
people and I can explain a little more
require,
require for,
for their health,
certain dietary compliments and what are
called the parasympathetic dominance.
Right.
Which is more like the Eskimos require
red meat to be healthy.
You will not only never be fully
healthy,
but then you're at risk for developing
the,
the illnesses that parasympathetic
dominance develop like leukemia,
lymphoma,
hypothyroidism,
you know,
chemical sensitivity,
chronic fatigue,
depression.
Right?
So many,
many,
um,
former vegetarians converted from
vegetarianism because they felt
depressed,
right?
So while that's true,
on the other side of the spectrum are
the sympathetic dominance who don't need
to eat red meat and who do really well
on like a full force like plants,
grains,
you know,
even a high carb diet and they feel well
and it's when they eat too much red
meat,
particularly industrial red meat that
they developed solid tumors like,
you know,
breast cancer or pancreatic cancer,
colon cancer as this is a very common,
you know,
so essentially when you're dealing with
particularly indigenous populations and
people that have a,
a very strong gene pool to comes from
one very strong area in the world,
like the Eskimos or like people that
live in the Pacific northwest or
something like that.
Uh,
not Pacific northwest,
but you know what I mean,
like Alaskan people,
there's people that live on like
pneumonia vac and all these different
islands that have eaten seal for
hundreds and hundreds of years and have
very little access to vegetables,
right?
And meanwhile,
they're healthy,
super low instances of cancer.
Okay.
So is it just because their bodies have
adapted and evolved for those
requirements with the environment?
Right,
exactly.
That's exactly what your body like.
Say if you came from Vietnam,
you would have a very different
nutritional requirement then that person
was right.
Yeah.
And you will never be fully vital or
healthy on the wrong version of the
Diet.
No.
Just all science.
Or is this an anecdotal guests?
So when it comes to nutrition based
science,
there ain't none.
There's just none.
Because the idea of nutrition research
is like taking one nutrient out of the
context of the person out of the context
of their life,
out of the context of their cultural,
you know,
his surroundings.
That's how we treat.
We treat it like a pharmaceutical.
We,
we look at single nutrient out of,
you know,
a whole compliment of information.
So we just don't,
I tried learning about nutrition that
way and I drove myself crazy because I
was like,
what the hell do I tell my patients eat?
I can't find any science to support
this.
And that's why I looked for outcomes.
So Nick Gonzales is,
outcomes are unprecedented in medical
history.
Literally like 34 year terminal
pancreatic cancer survivor you how long
you have to live when you're diagnosed
with pancreatic cancer,
like three to six months.
Any of those here's
on it.
But he's actually taking meds and uh,
that's a very,
very amazing,
they still eat sugar.
This fucker.
He's doing his thing.
Gummy bears and shit.
Um,
do you know Rob Wolf?
Do you know Rob Walters?
Yeah,
not personally.
I know his work.
Rob's a really interesting guy and one
of the things that he does that's kind
of a fascinating is on his instagram.
He and his wife will do these tests.
They'll um,
they'll do carbohydrate absorption tasks
and Ketosis a tests and they'll both eat
the same things,
but he'll test her and then test him.
And the results vary widely.
Yes.
His,
his reaction is
like,
he just jokes around about how poor his
genetics are and how about how robust
his wife's genetics are.
Apparently like nothing can knock
craddick ketosis.
She can eat like crazy amounts of food
and then like a couple hours later she's
like back on baseline.
Whereas his buyers all are like his body
just goes off the tracks.
Yeah,
he's weird.
Yeah.
So his um,
studies though,
and it's a little tests,
although you know,
they're very small.
It's just him and his wife.
They're really fascinating to see how
two people who are in the exact same
household,
same environment,
you know,
one's male,
one's female,
but also just different genetic and
backgrounds and how wildly they vary.
It's really,
so what do you do with that?
Right,
right,
right.
How do you know who you are in medicine?
Right?
So,
so the truth is that you have an
intuitive compass,
right?
Especially with food.
You are going to want to eat the diet
that is going to make you well,
candy and ice cream.
It's intuitive.
Dude.
I knew it.
If you actually like take this break and
detox,
so to speak from all those addictive
foods and you have this shift in your
body,
you're not going to want it.
You're going to be with the wrong cause
Tiramisu after you have like a nice
dinner and you see that on the menu,
you're like,
come on,
roll it out,
let's do this.
Get that cream with the photo on the top
of it.
So good.
It's gross.
So we should've never liked it.
Oh,
I quit coffee like nine years ago and
now I'm one of those ladies.
What about the chocolate ice cream?
Is that okay?
Nothing doesn't do anything for you.
Well you're like some sort of an android
then what's wrong with you here is into
this stuff.
So that's,
it starts to like deep condition and
then if you like really,
really feel like something like that,
then you're,
you're like,
what's up?
Like what am I like?
You know what I mean?
Like what the fuck is up?
Shit is good.
If you ever had like an ice cream
Sundae,
whipped cream.
I grew up in New Jersey.
I was born,
went to friendly's like on the regular
and I got the happy ending.
Can you believe it was called that
Sunday?
I know.
And the fries and a grilled cheese I
used to eat.
Sounds good.
Through my training,
I trained at Bellevue in New York and at
the gift store they used to know me so
they'd have twizzlers and dark
chocolate,
milky way waiting for me every day,
every day.
So I was like an addict,
you know by any definition and you can
resolve that,
you know,
and then out what actually your meant to
eat.
Cause Nicco we said you will eat the
food that you're meant to eat,
you'll want it,
but you have to sort of get your brain
out of the way.
So if you have,
you know,
all of these nutrition gurus in your
head telling you like red meat's going
to kill you and give you a heart attack,
then you're gonna not want it.
That's why I demand the openness as a
criteria,
you know,
to,
to participate with me anyway,
the clinical setting because then like I
can't
tell you how many of my patients were
former vegans and now they're totally
thriving.
Okay.
So let me finish telling you about
alley,
which I didn't finish line.
Okay.
So that's basically what she did,
right?
She was off all meds except for as,
as needed Klonopin,
uh,
when she met me.
So she had already done,
what does Klonopin do?
It's like Adavan like the one we were
talking about with Chris Cornell.
It's an antianxiety medicine like Xanax
or valium.
If you've heard of those.
Um,
it's one of the most challenging,
uh,
to get off of in the long term.
And that why wouldn't it be longterm?
Like that's the confusing part.
Like why would you just voluntarily stop
taking something that makes you feel
chilled out when you're feeling anxious?
Right?
But what if your anxiety is because you
have unstable blood sugar and you're
having this like fight or flight
explosion every hour and a half,
right?
If you're not resolving that,
then it's like putting a bandaid on a
piece of glass in your foot.
It's like,
okay,
but why don't you just fix it and then
you won't need it.
So you make them eat a certain amount of
red meat.
Do limit the portions to know there's no
calorie counting,
there's no portion anything.
Um,
because you are initiating yourself into
the process of determining what's best
for you.
So the whole point of this month,
this like military month that I impose
on people is that it's like an
initiation to your own self.
So the stuff you're doing,
whether it's the meditation,
enemas,
detoxing your products and stuff like
that,
basic,
you know,
functional medicine stuff or the Diet is
all in your control,
which is why you can do this without me,
which has been the best like evidence
I've ever,
you know,
I never even dreamed that was totally
possible.
And now I'm super pumped about it
because the last thing I want it to be
as like about,
you know,
the Kelly Brogan effect or something
like this at all what I'm interested in.
Um,
so yeah,
so you do all this yourself though,
besides road meat.
Okay.
So basically food.
Okay,
so you're eating animal food like
literally,
no,
but listen,
it's because tell me this isn't food.
It's animal food,
including,
you know,
any kinds of meat,
fish,
eggs,
whole eggs,
not just the way it's,
um,
any kind of vegetables except for white
potatoes.
I'll explain why.
Um,
any kinds of fruit,
nuts and seed seeds,
natural salts,
as much as you want,
tons of filtered water,
that's important.
And then natural fats,
so like ghee,
which is clarified butter,
coconut oil,
olive oil,
that kind of thing.
That's food.
By the way.
What you're taking out is a little more
challenging for some people.
So you're taking out all this is just
for the month.
It gets so much easier in the future.
But you're saying it all grains,
all beans,
all dairy and that.
So the ice cream is going and then all
refined sugar.
So like honey and maple syrup are fine.
And then coffee and alcohol.
But listen,
if you were really desperate,
you might think about this,
right?
And it can be challenging for the first
like week.
And then you start to see the dividends
and you want to just have one month in
your adult life where you just see
what's up.
When you control for these variables
it's worth it because then you know what
the sort of relationships are between
you and your personal,
you know,
biology and these,
elements of your nutrition.
So what's the general reaction when you
get someone to get rid of processed
sugars,
cut out the grains,
cut out the,
the non science dairy and just eat
regular healthy food.
What's the,
what's a normal range
that sometimes you feel worse depending
on how much of this stuff you were
eating?
You can literally go through like a mini
withdrawal,
like headache,
fluid symptoms,
fatigue,
irritability,
the Keto flu.
Exactly.
Heartflow yeah,
or Paleo.
Exactly.
So that can be real from the coffee to
obviously anyone has ever tried to quit,
but it's like a couple days and then you
move through it.
And then when normally starts to happen
is you start to like sort of feel the
clearing.
Your energy is better,
your sleep is better.
One of the most interesting things is
how many people tell me that they sleep
better when they eat more red meat.
Like you would never make that
connection.
Right.
Sounds crazy.
I didn't mention this.
I hope it goes without saying that
there's like massive,
like millet and focus on organic and
sourcing.
Like I would tell people never to touch
an animal food if they don't know,
you know,
that it was consciously raised.
Okay.
So that's a caveat.
Important caveat.
So I'm,
so sleep gets better.
A lot of the like ravenous hunger,
like I have patients who can't even go
as long as we've been talking without
like having a snack or they get hangry,
right?
Like they got like irritable light
headed,
you know,
sort of racing heart.
Yeah,
pretty much.
But like,
who is it,
you know,
when you're just eating convenience
food,
like that's a natural response.
Um,
and then sometimes as much more radical.
So like in,
in alleys case within two cycles,
she was completely symptom free.
So she went from grossly psychotic and
suicidal to not only totally symptom
free,
but now she's like moved through,
is moving through,
I would say a process of awakening.
Like it's a spiritual shift,
right?
Because it's like,
you know,
good Braun says like the,
the wound is where the light enters and,
and we don't have that consciousness as
a society because we think that
suffering the wound is where the light,
it means that grief,
pain,
suffering is where you grow.
Like it's where the real experience of
being human and where the real contact
with who you are.
Right?
So,
so this is true even for something like
Iowasca,
like why would anyone ever do something
like that?
Right?
But the point is through that experience
of humbling surrender,
you meet yourself,
right?
But we don't have a consciousness for
that in America.
In fact,
crying,
like literally tears is a symptom in the
DSM.
So,
so it's literally a pathological symptom
to cry.
That is the most basic evidence of our
humanity is that we cry.
And if we are living in a culture that
says,
you're sick when you're crying,
stop doing that.
You know,
take this so that you can stop feeling.
We have a bigger problem on our hands,
right?
So I know I can't just sit in my Madison
Avenue Office taking people off of meds.
And think like,
Oh,
you know,
I'm changing the world that this is a
systemic cultural issue that we make no
room for things to fall apart.
We make no room.
Do you know that with the Dsm five.
So like the latest Dsm,
they took out something called the
bereavement clause from the depression
diagnostic category.
And that means that if you meet criteria
for depression,
which is what you would imagine,
you know,
what the changes in sleep changes in
appetite,
low mood,
poor concentration,
um,
hopelessness.
If you meet that criteria it for two
weeks.
It doesn't matter if your kid just died
or your wife,
uh,
or like your dad.
So that's bereavement,
right?
It doesn't matter.
You're still a candidate for treatment
or if you got fired or a few experience,
natural disaster doesn't matter.
Or if you lost your house in a fire,
right.
It doesn't matter.
Right.
So some people saw that as like,
wow,
really a last straw of pathologizing
normal human experience.
So there's that.
One of the issues with these
disassociative sort of uh,
chemicals that people get put on cause
that's like one of the ways to describe
a lot of people's reaction to ssrs and
antidepressants is a dis associative.
Yes.
They have a very,
they can,
anything can happen in their okay with
it.
It's fine.
No worries,
no big deal.
So they don't get these highs and lows
and so because they don't get the lows,
they don't get the rebound and get the
highs and then also find themselves,
understand themselves so they can manage
how low the lows get through the mind
and through your just living in the
moment and understanding.
Exactly.
Understanding that there's a just a
natural process of life and you've been
through it before.
So instead of taking a pill,
just suck it up
100%.
I mean we don't write like in,
in in tribal cultures like men are
initiated,
right?
Oh I've got a video,
I'll show you,
say really tooth yanked out or you going
to like survive in the wild for can
circumcision video if you really want to
get crazy,
my guess.
Yeah.
One wells,
you know,
so we think of ourselves as being lucky
like that.
You don't have to do that though.
I sure I'm not taking responsibility for
what's in his video as being in any way
related to what I'm talking about.
No,
it's definitely not,
you wouldn't approve.
But it's
true.
Like we were just like,
we just bb our way through life because
no one is teaching us how to,
to confront our deepest fears.
You like explore the shadow realms and
integrated into our own power.
Right?
We have no understanding of it.
We make fun of that.
We think it's like woo weirdness that
like other cultures can,
you know,
do in their little tropical islands.
But what I have found is that taking
people off of Psych meds,
um,
somehow is seeming to serve as like an
initiation process for like thousands
today.
So interestingly,
right,
like that you took it because you
thought it was a good idea and it's so
challenging to come off it and forces
you to confront a lot of elements of
your consciousness live differently.
It forces you to work with your body
differently.
It forces you to begin to look at why
you went on them in the first place.
And then there's a whole nother layer of
just,
it's being really physically disabling
in some cases to come off these meds and
it really brings you to your knees
sometimes.
And so a lot of what I think of myself
as doing is just like a holding space
for that process to happen.
And then once it happens,
they move through into this like
awakened stay.
I mean the vast majority of my patients
and you know online course completers go
on to become healers.
Why else would that happen if they will?
People crazy.
That's why you're turned to healers,
but surely a massive blow back from just
conventional psychiatric medicine
practitioners who are looking at what
you're saying and like,
so you're telling someone all they have
to do is just stop eating sugar and they
won't be psychotic anymore.
That's fucking crazy.
I know you're not saying that,
but I'm,
I'm boiling it down to that.
You're saying that you took this woman
and you took her off of processed foods,
you made her eat healthy vegetables and
meat and eggs and healthy fats,
coconut oil and avocado oil and detox
and medication and all the inflammation
went away.
The problem of the,
the,
the insulin spikes and all the blood
sugar spikes that goes away and then the
body somehow or another comes back to
some sort of a baseline.
That's right.
And you know,
in the New England Journal of Medicine
recently,
there was a case report,
right?
37 year old woman who was so psychotic
that her family took out a restraining
order on her.
Okay.
Paranoid,
delusional,
totally psychotic.
She was treated with risperdal and
Zoloft and anti psychotic and an
antidepressant which did nothing a year
of this nonsense.
Later she was finally diagnosed with
gluten sensitivity.
Okay,
so wheat sensitivity,
right.
They put her on a three.
This is in the hospital.
This is not like in some quacks office,
you know in,
in boulder they,
there you go.
After bulldog.
It's one spot though.
That is a spot.
And Sedona,
that's an incident.
I'm going actually
next week.
I can't wait to check it out.
Totally.
So.
So in three months on this strict gluten
free diet,
she was totally normal again.
Wow.
So this is not like a wellness fad.
There are real route drivers,
but we don't know what it is for you.
Right?
Like I said,
it could be physiologic where it's like,
you know,
there's a similar story about a lifelong
vegetarian woman.
This is in the published literature,
um,
who became psychotically depressed,
was admitted for Catatonia.
Catatonia is like the worst diagnosis in
psychiatry.
Right?
She's basically unresponsive.
She was so mentally ill.
Okay.
They treated her with electric shock
therapy because the antipsychotics and
antidepressants,
they,
they used didn't work.
Finally she gets transferred to announce
that hospital cause they were like,
well,
we don't know what to do with this
woman.
They check her b 12 level and it's like,
you know,
tanked.
They give her a couple of b 12
injections.
And not only is she better,
but she's better than she's been in like
14 years from a couple of b 12.
And so my point is that for her it was
b12.
For her it was week.
For someone else,
it could be blood sugar,
instability for someone else.
Thyroid,
autoimmune thyroid can make you crazy,
can make you suicidal according to the
literature.
It's not a theory,
right?
You ever had anybody that you put on
this diet and they didn't respond,
they stayed psychotic or whatever.
Here's why.
Not a long time because I screened for
readiness,
right?
So I screened for a mindset and that's
what we're talking about earlier because
if you're ready and you believe that
you'd like a whole radical next chapter
of your life is like forthcoming,
then I,
I'm just part of the ritual,
you know?
And it's like using the placebo effect
even,
I don't know.
I mean,
I'm very interested in science,
but it is a belief that if you don't
believe that this is going to do
anything for you and you're a skeptic,
it won't.
It won't.
And I can show you all the science in
the world and it won't work for you.
But the physiological changes of
adjusting your diet,
those are real.
Right?
So like why won't it?
But your beliefs can even override that.
Whoa.
I think that's true.
Okay.
So I'll tell you about another study.
So these are people like your friends
and millions of others who think they
are treated to remission.
Think medication really helped them.
Right?
With PROZAC.
Okay.
So they're like,
well on Prozac,
okay,
so they're put in this study 12 week
study and they get to either stay with
their same dose of Prozac that helped
them or they get crossed over to the
placebo arm,
the sugar pill arm,
and they don't know which is going to
happen.
Right.
So what happened interestingly in that
study is that the time they were crossed
over or not,
they both,
both groups became statistically
significantly depressed,
right?
So like Mary takes her 40 milligrams on
Tuesday,
enters the study is still taking her 40
milligrams like next Thursday.
But now all of a sudden she's acutely
depressed just because of the
possibility that she might have gotten
the sugar pill.
That's called the no cbo effect.
So the no cbo effect is the impact of
fear or negative beliefs that limit your
ability to respond to a given
intervention.
It's real.
It's more important than anything we're
actually doing is what you believe
convinces you that Krispy Kreme donuts
and could fix you literally might be
some truth to that.
There could be.
And,
and I will,
I would have Kuwait on some level like
psych meds with Krispy Kreme donuts.
So there are some people who are going
to say like,
wow,
that really helped me.
So,
so this Guy Irving Kirsch,
right?
He's a psychologist who's,
who's like a placebo effect expert.
Arguably what,
what he identified was that when you
control for what's called the active
placebo effect,
which is what happens when you feel the
side effects,
you've been warned about of a given
medication and then you feel the
medication is working and then it
actually works,
right?
So when you control for the active
placebo effect by giving people in a,
in a trial,
um,
uh,
antidepressant,
but then also a medication like atrazine
for example,
that has very similar side effects,
dry mouth,
headache,
constipation,
this kind of thing.
There's no difference.
So what he showed is that there is no
statistically significant effect of
antidepressants above and beyond
placebo.
And that the reason that people believe
that they're working and they are right,
so they believe it and then they do is
because they feel a shift.
They feel a change and they've been
educated by commercials and their doctor
maybe about these side effects.
And then they start to say,
oh,
my chemical imbalances being adjusted.
Right?
So it's a,
it's subtle,
but this is not just in psychiatry.
It's really relevant to psychiatry,
but it's true in surgery.
You know,
they do sham operations in orthopedics
and it's true in,
in even,
you know,
um,
pain management,
you know,
that the placebo effect is so real and
it's not like you're being fooled.
So like,
you know,
like in,
in my training,
I was taught to dismiss the placebo
effect.
Like some nuisance,
we have to control for it,
but it's,
if we could,
Bruce Lipton said this,
like if we could harness this,
we would have a side effect free
medicine for everyone,
you know,
but we don't study it.
We don't understand it.
And we just assume it's like people
being tricked or something,
they go onto placebo effects.
Fairly Limited.
Like nothing really truly
miraculous.
It's true.
It's about 30%.
But that's exactly the efficacy of
antidepressants is,
is around 30%.
So there was a study once that was done
on some,
a kid
who had some horrible war disease,
um,
where they,
it was incurable and it was like
spreading all over their body,
over their arm,
do you know,
this study?
And they gave this kid some sort of a
placebo and it completely cleared it up.
And that's amazing.
I should know that.
Yeah.
And then when they found out that it was
a placebo,
then it became a problem and I think it
came back.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
I think that there's something going on
with the mind and the body.
Right.
And that's what the placebo effect is
demonstrating.
Right?
But this is unharnessed and this is uh,
untrained and this is very different
than what's going on with the mind with
meditation,
which is harnessed and trained and
focused.
So your thought is that this mine factor
is not just an inconvenience,
it's not just a,
a variable,
but maybe one of the most crucial
aspects to overall health,
if not the most crucial.
Yeah.
And again,
conventional medicine is interested in
this to some extent.
Now noticing that what people believe
like that,
you'll lose less blood in surgery if you
visualize losing less blood and surgery,
that that actually happens.
How can you control the physiologic
activity of your body?
But you can,
that's what I'm saying.
Like we have soft proof that it's,
it's a,
it's a study on power.
How did they convince them that they're
gonna lose last broad?
They met it.
They visualize it,
they meditate on it and visualize losing
less blood.
So they have one group that says you're
going to do a visualization where you
just like visualize your body letting go
of less blood after the surgery or
during the surgery.
And then the other group does,
does their thing know if you have one
group you say,
dude,
you're gonna Spray like a fountain.
He'll look a broken fire hydrant.
You're going to just big gush over the
table.
You're going to be a sprinkler.
You're right.
You should conduct this study.
That would be fascinating to see if the
no CBO affects would have it probably
would they?
Probably what?
Uh,
yeah,
I would imagine there's probably a way
you could mind fuck someone into some
terrible state.
Right?
That so you know where we see this is in
cancer diagnosis is called medical
hexing.
That you know,
when you are diagnosed with cancer,
your risk of your,
you know,
the completion of suicide,
but also other accidents and your health
basically declines simply because of the
diagnosis.
And that's why it's considered to be,
it's like bone pointing or something.
So it's Voodoo.
It's what we've always known that like
someone could put a hex on you and if
you know that a hex is on you,
you're like,
God damn,
there's a God damn hex on me.
That's when you start believing it and
then it could really cause a huge issue.
I,
that's what I,
it has become clear to me is real and we
don't want to think about it that way
because we think medicine is science and
it's,
you know,
this,
sort of impenetrable.
Well you know the hallowed halls of
truth,
but it's a religion just like anything
else.
In fact,
nick and Saul is,
my mentor said it's the last really
unrecognized religion on the planet is
medicine and you know,
we have special language and we were
costumes.
There's initiatory
rights.
We're talking about the hazing process
real in a lot of aspects like the
medicine involved in treating a
bacterial infection,
antibiotics,
medicine involved in healing,
a broken arm.
You know,
there's,
there's real stuff there too.
Next is a whole nother conversation for
sure.
Emergency medicine.
Listen,
if,
if you know,
I get hit by a bus,
don't like bring me to my,
don't pronounce my natural path in her
is going to love it.
Exactly.
It's gonna be fine.
Just go changing my body,
um,
for emergencies
sees that's what conventional medicine
is really designed for.
We only ran into trouble when we started
extrapolating from acute,
uh,
setting medicine into the outpatient
world.
Well also the denial of the aspects of
nutrition.
I did denial the influence of nutrition
like this,
this idea of the only concentrating on
the medicine and not concentrating on
what we know to be viable alternatives
and things that can make your body
healthier.
Like not taking that into account seems,
it seems almost insane.
It seems like you're going to fix a car.
Like I hear a banging,
I'm just gonna inflate these fucking
tires and you know,
like,
well,
what about the engine?
There's a banging in the engine.
Should I fix the engine?
Like,
no,
no.
I just turn off the alarm.
Like let's just turn the AC on.
Like it's almost like there's,
there's certain aspects they're looking
at the aspects of medication and because
of all the aforementioned variables,
like student loans,
the consensus of your peers,
everybody is in this sort of group
together is all the unspoken word that
you're not going to criticize the
establishment.
And you can't really do that because if
you do,
you're out of a job and all your money
that you spend on God.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
it's important to remember that the
pharmaceutical industry is a business,
right?
When you,
when you forget that and you think that
they're in it to protect your wellbeing,
help us.
I see.
If you forget that,
which is easy to do,
especially because they work with
doctors and we think of doctors says
priests sale,
right?
If you forget that,
then you can get into trouble.
Um,
because you take their word for
something you perhaps should be doing a
broader investigation on.
But if you remember that it's a business
and it's very lucrative,
successful business,
I mean,
it's the business model of all time.
Then you'll look with some
circumspection upon their claims and
their approach.
You know,
but our education as doctors is,
is totally through the lens of
pharmaceutical model.
You know,
regulatory agencies famously like the
FDA,
CDC and industry.
It's like a revolving door literally,
you know,
and this is totally available
information on the Internet that they're
all the same people.
So we really do have the Fox guarding
the hen house and that's where we get
into trouble.
If we don't have transparency around uh,
a true regulatory body that is not
fiscally invested,
we're have a problem,
especially for presenting this as the
only legitimate course of action for a
sick patient.
You know,
where,
where you can actually as a parent have
your children taken away from you if you
don't participate in the model.
Have there ever been any serious
suggestions that we remove this whole
ask your doctor commercial aspect of
medicine?
Like it just seems,
to my knowledge,
it seems so crazy that we know how
influential commercials are,
right?
I mean there are so influential and
these are not just fact based
commercials.
They've got cheery music.
Go on,
there's sunshine and butterflies and
shit.
And then it just makes you feel like
super happy.
Like I want to be like these people,
they're smiling all the time.
Totally conditioning crazy that,
that they can do that for drugs.
But you could argue,
you write that you're just empowering
patients with knowledge,
um,
to,
to help themselves.
Right.
Like that's why we're,
we're allowing the commercials.
Yeah.
Cause it's your doctor.
If abilify is going to keep you from
jumping off a bridge or make you do it,
ask your doctor like had,
so you said abilify was at one point in
time?
The most prescribed.
Yeah.
Recently it was the number one
prescription,
I think it was two years ago.
Um,
synthroids always up there.
But yeah,
it was,
and it's,
it's because it's it,
there's these trends I guess these
stylistic trends in prescribing that of
course have no evidence based.
But in psychiatry we're really
vulnerable to that because there isn't a
clear,
you know,
a to B in terms of presenting symptoms
and medication recommendation.
It's sort of a free for all,
you know,
you can pile on as many or as few as you
want.
And there are algorithms but they're
very loose.
Well,
you're trying to say scientology's
right.
Who said that?
That's kind of what you're trying to
say,
right?
I mean,
aren't they like Super Anti Scientology?
Remember when Tom Cruise was on,
what's his face?
What's that dude's name?
The Dude's name?
The Good Morning America guy.
He nail our Matt Lauer.
Matt,
you're Glib.
Matt.
Yeah,
he's been on out,
but an oprah who was one who was in
love.
He jumped off hand couch and he was in
love like no straight man who's ever
lived on the face of the planet.
He's his love.
Now I'm divorced,
but back then I was into it.
Um,
but no,
when,
when he was saying that on the Good
Morning America show with Matt Lauer,
he was essentially just saying what
scientology has always said.
Like if you go down sunset or Hollywood,
where's the psychiatry kills center?
Oh,
right.
You know,
I think it's on sunset.
There's some part of Hollywood people
with like electro shock helmets on like,
ah,
like it's like psychiatry kills.
Like,
what is this?
It's a fucking scientology center.
If you go in there,
they're like,
you don't need scientology.
You need to hold onto these cans that
are attached to the meter and we got to
find out what's ticking,
you know,
and then they start manipulating your
beliefs and that in turn helps you feel
better.
So there some sort of a correlation
between the mind,
you know,
getting out.
I mean,
you know,
in a way like they're almost like not
totally misguided in their efforts.
Right?
Yes.
And I would say an important difference,
um,
in my perspective perhaps.
And there's,
is that I believe in like individually
also,
you're not asking for 10% of all their
income and you don't require two and a
half hours of study every night.
Okay.
Yeah,
no,
it does.
So hopefully more differences than that,
but,
but no,
I mean it's,
you know,
if you're a subsuming someone into a,
I don't want to say cult culture.
How about a culture?
Oh,
that's cool.
I'm just pause before you say the chair
called.
Sure.
Then you're just transferring
dependence,
you know,
from one model to the next.
And you know,
sort of my bag is to really become
people back there.
Their power through a methodology
that's,
you know,
their own alone
that highlights why that stuff works for
people and why a lot of different things
work for people,
a lot of different kinds of religions
and unfortunately a lot of different
cults and a lot of different ideologies
and a lot of different mindsets do work
for people.
Even fucking crossfit.
There was a great article that I've read
about equating crossfit to,
um,
the fact that people do not have these
religious groups,
they don't have these social bonding
groups because they're not going to
church anymore.
So now they're going to this gym and
they'll like a lot of them literally
call the gym church.
Totally.
Yeah.
Have you heard of the rat park studies
rat park rat?
Like the rodent?
What does which studies on what?
So the,
there are these Canadian studies that
basically looked at the addictive model
of cocaine,
right?
So like you put,
we know right,
that if you put a rat in a cage by
itself and you give it the choice of
water or cook or cocaine,
right,
it's going to drink the cocaine until it
dies.
Yeah.
I'm,
or at least,
but then these,
yeah.
So then these researchers were basically
like,
well,
hold on a minute.
That's like totally a natural
environment for right to be.
And so if we,
what if we like put it in rat heaven
where it can like have sex with the rats
and hang out and have like a community
and there's things to play with and
little wheels and whatever.
Then what happens?
And if you give them cocaine or water,
they don't touch the cocaine and you can
even addict them in isolation and they
will voluntarily detox in Rad Heaven,
isn't it?
Yeah.
So what does that mean?
Right?
It means that we fundamentally need
community.
Like we need each other like it or not.
And we don't have that as a part of the
fabric.
We live in boxes.
We don't know our neighbors.
Like we don't have communities anymore.
Um,
and so any time we have the opportunity,
whether through aa or crossfit to to
plug into a community,
we fixed something inside ourselves so
we have less of a vulnerability to,
to abuse,
uh,
the effects of a substance like okay,
in her,
right.
It doesn't have the rat park studies so
important because so many people will
cite that as evidenced that cocaine is
so incredibly addictive when they,
when they find out about this,
because
this is a different variation on that
study and they,
oh,
well,
okay,
well I'm in a rat park.
Yeah.
The context matters me,
you're kind of in a rat park every day.
If you're in a cubicle environment,
you're in your car in traffic,
or you're on the bus and no one's
talking to anybody,
you're,
you're in your little cubicle by
yourself,
you know,
with,
and then there's shared suffering that's
coming from things like crossfit.
We have these,
hey,
these moments are you bonding together.
I'm just like,
you guys are,
you know,
you're in the trenches,
right?
Yeah.
There's something,
there's something to yoga class like
that people get all sot nom nom.
I stay on you.
I mean there's a lot of that.
There's a lot of struggles.
It's hard.
Yeah,
yoga is really hard.
And that's part of what's good about it
is that we need,
I think we need hard things.
I think your body,
if you're just constantly nerfed and
everything's soft and everything's a f a
free ride and there's no ops or downs
and everything's middle.
Like what is that?
That's not a human,
it's not live.
It's not what you're designed for.
So like when you're having a difficult
window in your life,
you know,
and maybe you know why,
like you had a loss.
I mean you don't know why and things are
just off,
right?
Like either you have a consciousness
that says there's something here.
You know,
there's something to this.
There's some meaning to this.
I got to look deeper.
I got to pay attention to things.
I got to rebalance in different,
I got to up my game,
you know,
self care.
Or you're like,
this sucks.
I don't want to feel this way.
And there are thousands of prescribers
like happy to open their door to you.
So that is really the problem,
right?
The real problem is that there's so many
different options other than what's
going to make you healthy and there's so
many different ways to just numb this
whole experience.
Just numb it all down.
Like let's put some ice on a baby.
You're going to be fine.
Let's numb this whole thing down.
I,
I have been of the opinion,
especially over the last few years,
I've really focused on this heavily and
I've talked about it maybe too much,
but I think people need to struggle in
order to appreciate how nice things are
and also to mitigate the effects of
actual bad things that happen to you.
If you can do difficult,
hard things on a daily basis,
on a regular basis,
you know,
whatever your schedule allows for.
But whether it's martial arts or whether
it's yoga or whether it difficult
struggle,
physical struggles where you have to
test yourself.
Yeah,
we have to pull through.
You have to have discipline and resolve
and it's hard to do.
When you get through that you,
you develop that muscle and that
understanding of struggle and believe it
or not,
this is where it's going to seem really
weird.
The struggle that you get in a yoga
class is so much harder than the
struggle that you'll ever experience
outside of that make any sense.
Like,
no,
you're going to work out like this is
just like,
no,
this is not spin class,
man.
This is something like very intense and
not that spin class I'm all about.
So second spin are too,
I mean it's a
bad example.
What I should say is it's not like going
to the gym and doing like a,
a simple round of like calisthenics or
exercise or your discomfort.
Real serious discomfort,
right?
Where you want to quit,
you want to stop and you have to push
through.
And that intense focus on difficult
things,
it makes life more bearable.
It makes more enjoyable.
My awakening,
so to speak,
began when I gave birth for the first
time,
right?
Yeah.
And I had a natural birth and she's
doing a bathtub.
Did you get crazy?
So the second time I did a birthing
center the first time and second time I
had a home birth.
Why'd you do that though?
What if there was anything wrong?
I need to get to the hospital.
Um,
it's interesting because my first birth
I was still in the matrix,
right.
So like I was still eating Mcdonald's
and you know,
prescribing and you liked that kid less
than the second code.
You have the matrix baby.
It's totally.
Then it meanwhile she's like,
let's say age.
She had to compensate for all my dark
energy.
Um,
so I actually had a natural birth
because of the science because I was
like in this real like no,
it all place in my life.
Um,
are,
believe it or not,
I've tried to move past that but I had
this ob at the time and I was like,
she doesn't know what she's talking
about.
And I researched like,
what does the evidence show ob?
It's actually like psychiatry.
Only about 30% of obstetrical practices
are evidence based and the rest is
consensus.
Like the rest is just,
they're just doing it because they're
doing it like the cords wrapped around
the baby.
Dang.
What if nothing,
we've been doing this since the
beginning of time and if you died since
the beginning of time because of these
things.
So we actually have a home birth versus
hospital birth data,
which it should be totally unnecessary.
Right?
But we actually have it at this point to
demonstrate that that's like patent.
It's fear mongering.
It's like patently false.
People do get choked by a biblical
courts,
right?
Yes.
Certainly.
Anything is possible.
Of course that's going down.
But the truth is that when you,
when you researched the interventions
you will find,
so I had a natural birth because the
research that I did on the
interventions,
things like fetal monitoring,
a PCR,
atomy,
even ultrasound,
let alone csection,
you know,
antibiotics during delivery,
et cetera.
What I found was that there wasn't
science to support them and actually the
science suggests that they should be
abandoned.
So what I was left with was the code of
silence with Josh should be abandoned.
These interventions.
C-Sections.
Yeah.
Oh,
I mean the consensus,
even the WHO,
um,
which is part of the machine,
but even even the WHO says they should
be less than 10%.
I mean,
they're over in New York,
there are upwards of almost,
almost 40% of births.
Birds.
Are they doing that to save the vaginas?
They're doing it because they don't want
to feel bad feelings and they don't want
to feel pain.
It's exactly what we're talking about.
I've heard women like specifically say
they don't want to get stretched out.
I don't think that's a big yes,
certainly.
But I don't think that's a huge
motivator.
I think people are really,
women have been made to feel afraid of
their own bodies.
It's the birth control thing we were
talking about earlier.
If you think of your body as a total
pain,
you know,
that's dangerous,
is gonna fuck up at any given time.
And you're going to,
you know,
wish you had listened to your,
doctor who's a man and he's never had a
baby.
Then you could obviously be led down
this path that says,
let me manage your body.
I know better science knows better how
to do this.
Your body,
it messes up all the time.
Right?
So that's the mentality.
And in that mentality,
in my opinion,
is that you're robbed of this
opportunity,
like psychedelic level opportunity to
have a transformation of your
consciousness.
Because it is hard and it is scary and
it breaks your mind.
My mind broke on that day broke,
and it's never been recovered because it
was literally so intense that my mind
was telling me,
you're gonna die.
You're gonna die,
you're gonna die,
you're gonna die.
It's like pain.
But it's more,
more than that.
It's not pain that you've ever,
you would recognize because it's,
it's purposeful pain.
It's not just a signal of something
wrong,
right?
So it's,
it's a sensation that is a part of the
process of moving a human being through
an out of your body.
So it's not,
we call it pain,
but you know,
midwives don't call it pain,
for example.
It's not pleasure either.
It's just another thing.
It's another thing.
So screaming,
because when you're in that intense
portal,
you moan,
you have the,
there are these primal sounds.
We make,
you know,
when we're making love or when we're
experiencing,
you know,
fear when we're,
we're really in it,
you know,
we make those kinds of sounds and,
and,
and there is a lot of fear.
But ultimately if you don't succumb to
it,
you,
it breaks and you see,
oh that was trying to tell me I couldn't
do this and look,
I just did it.
Do you ever think that if you could meet
your old self that your old self bilic
listen to this crazy bitch?
100%.
I wouldn't even have hung out with me.
Like talk to me at a bar.
Coon lenient placebos.
Huh?
What do you want me to do?
Eat eggs.
The Fuck Outta here.
This girl is crazy pills.
Oh,
you need pills?
You're delusional.
You're talking about healers and
holistic medicine.
It would have been the eye roll all
total.
That's hilarious.
How do you,
uh,
how do you,
you know,
reconcile that?
Because I feel myself like I feel 100%
myself.
And that is,
it's there's zero self conscious aspect
of it where you do recognize that there
are certain science based practitioners
that will be like rolling their eyes at
you.
Oh,
I don't care.
You don't care.
I don't
care about that.
And it was interesting,
right?
So I published this book last year in
March,
but what's it called again and mind of
your own and I published it.
It was really weird experience because
I,
you know,
I was total newbie.
I'd never written a book before,
whatever and out the gate I got like
this very generous advance from a
mainstream publisher,
which shocked me and then it comes time
to publish it and they can't get me on a
single,
you know the today show Doctor Oz 60
minutes and they're used to waltzing
their authors who they give these large
advances to like write onto these
platforms,
right?
Mainstream media platforms.
I told them is not going to work with me
like you haven't worked with someone
like me before.
Trust me,
it's not going to work out.
These are all Pharma funded outlets,
even NPR,
pbs,
they all are.
So,
you know,
we're going to have to come up with
something else.
And ultimately they didn't listen and
they started to Baz when I,
a month before launch,
didn't have a single interview,
they'd never had that happen before.
And so it was cool because alt media,
you know,
like this,
I just called on a bunch of my friends
and colleagues and we,
it was like top 20 on Amazon within the
first week.
And that's like the power,
like mainstream media is totally dead.
And I have tell you that,
but it was so quiet for like the whole
year afterward.
If you Google my book,
there is not a negative review of this,
like very controversial text on the
Internet.
Very weird.
Because we have trolls on our site every
single day on facebook for example.
Or you know,
twitter,
even instagram.
It's like part of the deal of being an
activist is that you deal with
astroturfing and you deal with that
whole,
you know,
sort of strew turfing.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
you should.
There is um,
an amazing ted talk that you need to
watch by Sharyl attkisson who's like a,
um,
a turncoat journalist,
right?
Like she used to be an anchor,
I don't know where.
And so she has this Ted talk on
astroturfing and she basically breaks it
down.
Astroturfing is like what?
So the word,
right?
It's because it's like a fake grassroots
movement.
I'm on social media,
right?
So it's paid industry paid bots
basically who generate the impression
that there is an opinion anti anyone who
threatens the establishment.
Right?
And then they,
there are people who like organically
glom onto that.
So they create this,
this,
okay,
so they'll come on my site by the
thousands.
Right.
And it immediately after a comment is
written,
like you quack,
like,
where did you get that fake medical
degree?
Like you're killing people.
You should be ashamed of yourself.
You're reckless and yeah,
exactly.
And they almost always call me it's
water account.
That's like almost always part of it.
That's how you know,
and there'll be like 500 likes within 10
minutes.
That's like one of the indications that
it's a troll.
You know what I mean?
So like there'd be a face on the note
that that's a troll and not just people
resonating with this idea that the hate
quarks,
cause I don't have that many people on
my facebook page so that that would ever
be a metric.
You know,
it's,
it's not even like probably
algorithmically possible that it would
be an organic phenomenon.
Did you see that thing recently?
Jamie brought it up yesterday about
Donald Trump that turns out that he just
had millions of bots follow him on
twitter.
Just letting I know where it's like
something like 4 million bots.
Yeah.
Just joined on and everyone's like,
okay,
what's going on here?
What happened here?
What is this?
These are fake accounts.
Yeah.
It's like a thing that's,
you know,
it's not surprising that part of the
data that they can manipulate.
This is half of president trump's
twitter followers are bots.
Right?
Holy Shit,
this is so crazy.
So you generate the impression that
there's a grassroots energy and that
it's actually not real.
He picked up 3 million twitter followers
in recent days,
most of which appear to be recently
created twitter bots,
screenwriter,
John Nivon pointed out Tuesday morning
that trump's account saw a big spike in
followers over the weekend.
Most of them newly created accounts
without photos or tweets,
right.
Tells Herald Times signs of twitter
bots.
Wow,
that's crazy.
So that is something that they're doing.
They're making it an active campaign.
Sort of boast up is a public appeal and
is
right.
And in that case,
you know,
I don't know specifically,
but in that case it would be to generate
the impression that it's grass roots.
Right?
When it's not.
That's why it's called astroturfing.
God,
it's fake grassroots.
Got It.
Got.
But yeah,
so,
so I have all that energy in my daily
life,
but I didn't have a single negative
review of this book in like a year left
in the weird,
nope.
Says it's false.
Why this is mostly false.
Since president trump,
like other twitter users with large
following has a large number of
followers that appear to be bots or
inauthentic automated user profiles.
What's false?
Trump did not receive an influx of 5
million new twitter followers in three
days.
Oh,
so stops questioning.
Yeah.
How many did I thought they said 3
million.
I mean,
it says as of May 1st it had 28.5
so it couldn't have gone up that fast
over the month.
Cause it's Atlanta one and a half
million gain.
I don't know.
Uh,
that's not even not abnormal for someone
with that many millions.
He is 28 million.
Oh,
it could go away.
I don't know.
The story just got weirder,
so,
yeah.
Hmm.
According to the image archive images,
twins,
twitter page rumors of a surgeon.
Farmers were great.
Really exaggerated.
Wow.
That's,
that's,
that's fake news.
I mean,
it's what he's talking about.
Kinda jumped on the fake story,
Jack.
Yeah.
But I'm sure there's a ton of bots
following him.
I know there's a ton of bots following
me.
Yeah.
I get them all the time.
These women that are fake women that
want to talk about sex.
I come to come chat with me about sex,
come sex me up.
And they're like,
it's all like the worst broken English.
Like it's time to tried to have a
conversation with them.
And that worked out.
Who?
Who
explained it to it?
Yeah,
I tried to dm them.
They didn't ignore me.
Who tried to explain that to us that
they use intentionally?
Was it malice?
Was it Michael Miles that they used
intentionally shitty language so that if
you follow them,
like they're poor grammar,
sort of like alerts them to suspicious
people so that suspicious people don't
interact with them but dumb people.
So they are,
they're a honeypot that creates this
environment that stupid people are
attracted to it because they can't see
that grammatical errors because they're
dumb.
And so it makes it more effective.
So these Nigerian scammers apparently
purposely use bad grammar.
Like they're more than capable of using
good English,
but they use the shitty grammar so that
the people that they do get are just
really dumb.
They're not trying to snag like I was
trying to sell you the Ivy Leaguers.
Yeah.
Well anybody who's got a discerning idea
of,
you know what,
this may or may not be.
They're not,
they're not trying to get that.
They're trying to get the gullible and
there's plenty of them.
Like,
why,
why go fishing for sharks?
We can catch guppies,
you know,
and get nets fully guppies.
They came to that in a way through the
net.
It's this easy pickins still be able to
talk and try to catch a whale.
Dude,
that's too much work.
You know,
it's really interesting though.
It's,
um,
I mean if that is how sophisticated they
truly are,
it's kind of fascinating.
But when sort of know this stuff,
then you can interpret it.
You know,
it just helps to be aware of it.
It would be a big,
big deal if we found out that
pharmaceutical companies,
we're actively engaging in the use of
these bots to attack people like you.
Like if you had someone like wikileaks
on your side to like dug into this shit
and you know Scott,
some whistleblower from the
pharmaceutical industry that cares and
release that stuff,
that'd be pretty giant where I have some
colleagues working on that really don't
tell people now they're going to try to
cover their tracks.
They'll never know.
No,
I mean,
and the truth is that I don't think it's
going to require that because I think
people are waking up just by sheer,
it's like I synergy.
Like people are waking up,
they are calling bullshit on a lot of
the heavy handed claims of the
pharmaceutical industry.
They know that doctors aren't helping
them.
You know,
they know that the conventional model
has very limited ability to help them
and or they've tried it and it's not
worked.
So people are waking up and that's why
in more recent time I've focused my
energy not on fighting the sis like some
David and Goliath situation,
but I,
I'm just focusing on making sure people
know like what's possible.
It's like bucky fuller quote,
like you don't fight the existing
system.
You know,
you,
you create one that makes the existing
system obsolete.
Basically.
I don't know who made this quote,
but it's a wonderful one in this regard
that,
uh,
before diagnosing yourself with
depression first,
make sure you're not surrounded by
assholes.
Who's quote is,
it's a great quote,
great quote.
It is.
You know,
and also you might have a shitty life.
you might
be bummed out because you're working all
the time and a job,
it's uninspiring.
You might be bummed out because he got
an abusive spouse.
You might be bummed out because you live
in a crime infested neighborhood.
You might be bummed out for,
you know,
you might have some environmental issues
that are causing health problems.
So a lot going on.
You might work in a job that gets you
exposed to toxic fumes or chemicals or,
right.
A lot of variables.
We were in a medical system that blames
your biology.
That's it.
Yeah.
Just blames your biology.
So if it says it's convenient and
because it suits the paradigm that's in
place,
that's exactly right.
Is that what it should be?
A lot of people,
uh,
ascribe it to Freud.
Right.
But this a quote,
investigator.com,
he says that it actually should go to
this twitter account,
a twitter account,
which twitter account,
Debbie hope should be credited with the,
it says Debbie wizard,
you,
whoever it was,
she nailed it.
Did she nail it and attributed to Freud?
That's a kind of a clever move.
I don't want the attention version.
Yeah,
really awesome and attributed to some
dead dude who was a genius.
I found the site before they kind kinda
like do the telephone game with quotes
and sort of like this is what people are
saying.
And then they go through like this,
all the iterations of how it's been
translated out.
Do you remember that one Greg Giraldo
joke that got attributed to me online
and people have photos of me with Greg
draw those quote and something that I
never said.
It's absolutely not mine.
I didn't know whose it was.
And then someone had to say,
that's great girl.
Geraldo's and then people say like,
why are you stealing greg?
Geraldo shut my making memes.
Like,
I'm not doing that.
Somebody else did that,
but I put it on twitter.
This is not mine.
I think I might've put it on instagram
too long time ago,
but it was weird.
It was like I kept getting them.
Or you get them.
These memes come in waves.
You know,
I get ones that I did say I get those in
waves too.
I get these pictures of me with like
weird quotes that I'd said names are
very powerful.
Yeah.
Video is even more powerful though
because I think people have come to this
conclusion that they can't trust
anything anymore.
Names are funny.
That's one of the things that,
but like good solid shame.
That's one of the things that was so
egregious about that fat Jewish guy and
said he was stealing these brilliant
ideas and it made him look brilliant
when really he's just sort of this
aggregator of other people's awesome
ideas without giving them credit and he
just got on this plagiarism loophole and
everybody's like,
what?
And now he's got this weird thing that
he does where he says that he puts up
the meme.
He writes his own quote and then just
puts the originators name at the end of
it.
He doesn't even say originally created
by,
he just puts their name and that's like
attribute and credit and some sort of a
weird way.
It's super slimy like what's going on
now with like,
and the problem is like some,
it'll send you something and I have real
issue with this.
Like someone sends me something that's
hilarious and I want to it on instagram.
I'm like,
I don't know,
made it,
can I just put it up?
Like what do I do?
Do I say,
Hey,
I don't know who the fuck made this.
Let me know.
And then put it up and then people go,
oh,
just see what Joe Rogan said.
There's Hilariously,
I didn't say it.
It matters.
I'm big into attribution because it
makes it like,
it's like I have company around me,
you know,
I,
it's also people turn into a business.
Yeah.
Like the meme business is a business and
then they have sponsored posts,
sponsored instagram posts and sponsored
tweets and they make a lot of money.
Like there's a lot of money to be made
and people were getting these
development deals to do television shows
and all sorts of other things based on
the content of other people's ideas that
they're just aggregating.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Well it's just a weird loophole and it's
like if you were doing it with music,
like say if you just wanted to take
rifts that you thought were really
awesome and put them on your music page,
people will go,
well fuck you.
You can't do that.
This is my stuff.
I created this,
but we that signature,
unless you're putting watermarks on
everything,
that signature is not necessarily
available with mediums.
Right.
Cause they're that powerful.
Yeah.
And if even if you do put a watermark,
you know what they do,
they just find the original photo,
put their own quote over it and just
don't attribute anything to you because
they don't want you to have the
watermark on their page.
It's sneaky.
It's like some weird copyright loophole
that exists now.
You know?
No one knows exactly what to do about
it.
You need some ambulance chasing lawyers
to,
that's right.
Yes.
Ambulance chambers chasers,
so what blow back have you experienced
other than this influx of trolls and
people there is that for a whole year?
None.
Like I took out a large life insurance
policy when I published my book
expecting like pretty serious.
You could word you were going to die.
It's happened.
I have colleagues.
What do you,
what college did you have that have
died?
My,
no,
leave that mystery hangar,
but it's you think people have been
killed because they've criticized
pharmaceutical companies.
You just have to know that it's the most
powerful industry in the public eye
anyway.
That's intense though.
What you just said like you,
you have colleagues that you believe may
have been killing me.
You don't want to talk about it.
Obviously he'd clamp right up.
It's hard to shut me up.
It's hard to tell,
but you really believe that.
You know what I mean?
Is was like focus on this layman,
but I do.
You're lying.
It's powerful narrative habit that it's
a possible narrative.
They might silence you.
And in the,
in the realm of independent journalism
and media where some random Schmo like
me can actually have influence,
especially,
you know,
that I am credentialed in a way that
people might pay attention to.
Right then why would they not want to
quiet me?
But,
well,
they put labels on cigarettes.
No one gives a shit.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't know if what you're saying is
worth killing somebody over who,
I mean,
I'm still here,
so apparently not.
Right.
And what will know what I mean?
It means like all those whistle blowers
when it came to his cigarettes and
cancer,
those who gives a shit,
it's people there make more money from
cigarettes now than ever.
Less people smoke.
So they just charge more for cigarettes
and they make more than ever.
They make more now for cigarettes and
they have in the last 15 years.
Yeah,
no,
I believe that.
And,
and,
and it's true that just because,
but I,
right,
like I'm not just trying to scare people
out of taking meds and trying to help.
Also showing that you can totally shed
your chronic illnesses completely
forever macho forever,
but that you can have longterm shedding
of your chronic ells is.
That to me is a more threatening element
of what I have to say.
Then just like these pills are
dangerous,
you shouldn't take them.
I'm not saying that,
I'm saying you might have been told
you're broken,
that you have a mental illness for life,
but in fact,
you know,
like I have a woman who completed,
um,
my online program had such bad migraine
headaches that she had to be on Ivy
Treatments.
She was treated by the top neurologist
at emory.
She was on multiple pharmaceuticals.
She was bedbound for two years.
Okay.
And she completed my program,
which we talked about.
This is not rocket science.
Okay.
And she's totally symptom free.
Totally.
Yeah.
So that's pretty threatening,
right,
to,
to show you that in fact,
what you're told is a permanent problem
you just have to deal with and live
with,
with pharmaceutical medicine could be
completely dissolved as a very
threatening concept.
And I'm not the only one.
I mean many functional medicine doctors
and holistic healers are,
are,
you know,
working to create awareness of this
possibility.
But regardless,
it was pretty weird that,
you know,
the book made the New York Times list
strangely and there wasn't a mention of
it in mainstream media for a year.
Not once.
Like nobody wanted you to have to have
you on their show.
This is amazing.
I'm not a negative review,
like not a single mention in mainstream
media.
So the negative review is,
the problem with that is that you could
refute the negative reviews and also
cause tension attention on it.
Now let's see what her response is
decided to ignore me,
which I was totally cool with because I
had a very chill year.
But it's,
I'm your life insurance policy.
Yeah,
exactly.
Just,
just waiting,
uh,
you know,
to get my couple million to my kids.
But it's changing.
Even in the past month or so,
there's been like a more of a targeted
effort and a couple of allure and cosmo
and couple of mainstream outlets have
begun to um,
suggest that I am in,
you know,
a dangerous reckless person who shames
women,
um,
who,
who take meds.
They've said this in articles.
Yeah,
I mean you can,
yeah.
Wow.
I don't want to give it the claims quick
energy,
but not funny that like if you give
advice that is based on actual studies,
actual medicine,
give advice about,
you know,
like,
hey,
maybe it's not a good idea that you take
these crazy medications where we don't
exactly know why you're taking them.
We don't know exactly if these are the
right medications for you,
the testing them on you literally as you
go along that you're shaming.
I'm
not even saying maybe it's not a good
idea.
I'm just saying,
here's what the science says that you
might not have been told and here's
what's additionally possible.
You should just at least know,
okay,
and here's the social proof.
You know,
interviews,
I'm publishing for case reports as we
speak in the peer reviewed index medical
literature.
You know,
so this is not like some random blog I
wrote.
Okay.
So just know that that's possible and
then make your decision.
And guess what,
if you're on meds and this sounds
interesting to you,
then I'm showing you you,
there's a path to a new,
you know,
approach that's,
that's it.
But actually it hits even given airwaves
cause it's just sort of ridiculous.
And I do believe a lot of initiated with
astroturfing,
but I'm being called an ablest.
Never heard that word.
I never heard that word before.
Hundred folds,
one of the new ones that kids are using.
All these little snowflakes.
Good to know of it.
So like,
uh,
so I'm shaming people who can't do what
I'm able to do,
including have a home birth.
But this has been around for a while to
sort of,
I know you're a woman,
it's not as bad.
White woman privilege is not real it
Israel.
No it's,
it certainly is.
It certainly is.
But you guys have a struggle with that a
bit more.
Perhaps.
I'm a conqueror.
I'm a man.
Terrible person.
Done are things throughout history.
Clearly all men are responsible for all
the horrible stuff.
Yeah.
Able,
this is a wonderful term.
Do you ever use that Jamie?
No.
Call.
Anybody enabled us and actually done
well in college.
They do and they do online.
I don't know where I've been that I
never heard that term.
It's too easy to get by.
Sue.
Easy to eat.
It's too easy to survive is not enough
difficulty out there.
People go looking for insults and
looking for things that are off.
Yeah.
There there's a constant searching for
outrage.
This quest for recreational outrage,
you know,
and,
and people find things to be appalled at
and then attack them and go nuts over
it.
It's just,
it's a very strange time.
It's,
uh,
I think it's beautiful though.
I think it's all,
it's all really good.
Like we're,
we're coming to grips with how
preposterous we are and we're,
we're doing so in the middle of these
embroiled battles over ideologies,
over cultural expression.
I,
there's some girls in Portland that had
taken a rash of shit because they're
selling burritos and they're white.
They,
they made a burrito truck and people are
going crazy and trying to shut them
down,
shut them down because they're not
Mexican and they're selling burritos
like they're not,
you know,
they're not pretending.
They're not like putting shoe Polish on
and pretending and that put in brown
face on there,
just fucking selling burritos like it's
so crazy.
Its critics close.
White Women's Portland Burrito stand for
cultural theft.
What the fuck man?
Their burritos assholes.
Mexicans don't even eat burritos.
Yes they do.
Okay.
She's a Mexican expert.
Burrito's uh,
I've eaten Burrito's in Mexico food.
I have had a real chicken burrito in
Mexico and was quite delicious.
I love Mexico.
It's done a lot of it.
I just don't understand why anybody
thinks that there's something wrong with
learning a style of cooking.
It's like,
I think if you have cultural
appropriation,
if you have like a person who's
pretending they're from Laos and they
start talking with a fake accent and you
know,
and you go,
hey man,
you're full fucking Cleveland.
You're not even,
you're not even of Laos to scent.
Like you do a 23 and me on you and you
find out like your family is from
Finland.
Like the fuck is wrong with you.
Like,
but there are people that do that and
that is crazy.
Right?
But that's just deceptive.
This is not deceptive.
Is it someone who likes making Burritos,
they're making burritos and then these
goofy white kids are fucking closing
them down.
And that's what it is.
Cultural appropriation.
Heroes just shouting out from the
rooftop that you're wrong,
you're wrong.
It's like you said,
we're just always looking for who to
blame,
who to be mad at,
who to make sort of the,
the persecutor of our felt wrongness.
It's that same issue.
It's so crazy.
Yeah.
No,
it is a weird,
it is a weird time.
And the trouble is,
you know that the more that we,
this infighting is like in some ways a
distraction from the greater issues that
are sure government overreach and these
greater issues that are allowed to
unfold while we're busy calling each
other names and you're doing it on
twitter and the government's literally
reading your emails while you're doing
it and you're like,
no,
but we have to worry about this burrito
stand.
Do you think you're finding it salsa?
You can't have tortillas.
You're not from here.
Like what is wrong with people that
never existed before?
Like whatever.
Here's the thing,
here's what's fascinating.
It only works if the people that you're
supposedly culturally stealing from our
brown.
Like if you tried cooking French food
and you're not a French to send,
nobody gives a shit.
You could cook Italian food all day long
and no one cares about copd cultural
appropriation.
Like you could be a white woman from
Switzerland who lives in New Jersey and
runs an Italian restaurant and no one
cares.
They won't care.
Well,
arguably they haven't been like
oppressed,
I guess in the same way where at one
point in time we just got through it and
techniques.
It's Mexican,
but it mean for real.
I mean that's literally the path of
boxing in America was it was Jewish
people,
Italians,
Irish.
It was the suppressed people,
black folks.
It was always the people that were the
most economically suppressed that rose
to.
And then they were also like my
grandparents came from Italy and they
experienced horrible racism back then,
back in the early 19 hundreds but by the
time they integrate into society,
like being Italian isn't even thought of
as being not white anymore.
Yeah.
But when my grandparents were kids,
it was like,
just like being Mexican,
I was the same kind of thing.
It was like you were treated like
someone from somewhere else that they
didn't want here,
you know,
they called them Guinea waps and all
these crazy slangs
horrible expressions that don't even
mean anything anymore.
Right there.
It's so ineffective now and our hope is
right that one day it's going to get
like that with Mexicans the same way.
It's like you can't really mock someone
from being from Holland.
No one gives a shit.
Like you can say,
Oh,
you're from Holland.
Like,
yeah,
like it's not about Quito though.
Like does that,
it doesn't matter.
They call it as themselves Guido's like
family.
They call themselves Guido.
They'll call themselves guineas,
they'll call themselves and it's like
almost like a term of endearment and
it's power.
It's true.
It's totally lost its power because it's
culturally acceptable to be Italian.
And then one day,
I mean,
but the idea that these girls are
stealing from Mexicans where it's so
crazy.
Like,
Oh,
there's a salad burritos folks,
just food.
It's just a certain way of preparing it.
You know?
It's not like they're pretending we
event this and no one else did it.
It's a wrap.
Like the people who make wraps,
those should be slapped.
That's not how rap motherfucker,
that's a burrito.
You're making a Shitty Burrito and
you're calling it a wrap.
Right?
Gluten free.
Those are the real problem.
Those are the problem people.
They're calling it wraps.
That's looks like a Tortilla.
No,
no,
no rap.
What is,
what did they call,
did they call a rapid tour in?
They say it's a Tortilla.
What do they call that?
Outside of a rap,
right?
Like when you come up,
Dang.
Totally coopting right.
That's the real theft is raps,
but it doesn't even taste like if those
girls were just selling wraps,
everybody be like,
oh,
that's cool.
It's just a wrap.
They just mislabeled it.
As long as you don't have a Mexican flag
anywhere.
And he like a cartoon of a Chili Pepper.
It's just,
I,
I really feel like this goes,
I mean it's,
it's a stretch granted,
but I really feel like this goes back to
what we're talking about is that people
need difficulty in their life.
They really do.
And that way they don't seek out
difficulty.
Yeah,
no,
it's true.
And I think that's one of the reasons
why you're getting a lot of this from
these college kids where their tuition
is being paid for their,
you know,
they don't,
they don't have jobs.
They're not competing in the real world.
They're just operating on ideologies and
they're being taught by these
knuckleheads that are just trying to
keep their tenure and they're trying to
spread the same sort of ideology that
they had when they were in college and
they never really entered into the
workforce in a lot of examples.
A lot of these people went from academia
to teaching,
right?
I mean,
right in there,
just embedded into the system.
I don't really know,
hey Ho these racist teachers have got to
go,
right.
It's just people are going crazy today.
And I think a lot of it has to do at the
same thing.
I think it's this new found ability to
communicate,
which is fantastic and it's going to
have its hiccups and is going to be some
issues and he's going to be some,
some real coopting of the system,
like what you're experiencing with
trolls attacking an idea.
But overall those ideas are spreading in
a way that's unprecedented and
impossible just a few decades ago.
Like your ideas spreading the way they
have where I hear about them and now you
know,
you and I sit down and
talk about this.
Millions of people are going to hear
this conversation and this and this is
unprecedented.
Like this has never been available
before.
So all the bad stuff,
you've got to take it with all the good
stuff and it's dark 100% yeah.
I like what you expressing,
what you're trying to get out to people.
This is all this,
all new stuff.
Like no one was saying this 20 years ago
because we were all asleep.
He's matrix talk.
This is more hippy talk that you would
hate 20 years ago.
He'd be like,
Oh my God,
I'm so crazy when I'm older.
But that's why it's,
it is a cool time because it sorta like
the democratization of information where
if if you want to learn about other
perspectives on anything,
you look it up,
you know,
and then you make your own decision.
So it is a time where you have the
potential to be an individual in ways
that were not honored in,
in more conformist,
you know,
controlled media environment.
I mean,
the trouble is that many people are
still,
you know,
still believe that mainstream media is
telling them the truth,
that,
that deconditioning is very challenging.
Um,
but yeah,
that's a real problem.
I mean,
I think even though like the trump stuff
with all this fake news talk is so
detrimental,
ultimately it is like you're getting
people,
even if they realize this guy's a
knucklehead and he's wrong about a lot
of stuff,
they're gonna,
they're at least challenging these ideas
that these networks are only giving you
the news.
I mean,
Fox News is a Goddamn sexual assault
paradise over there.
I mean,
these,
these guys just keep getting kicked out
of Fox News over and over again.
There's all these sexual harassment
allegations and people are resigning
left and right.
Right.
Well because of all that stuff,
it makes you go,
oh,
these guys are creeps.
Like there's a lot of creeps even there,
like when Brian Williams got busted
lying and you're like,
oh that news guys just like another
asshole.
They just make shit up.
Like just because he's saying the real
news sometimes doesn't mean everything
he says is true and there's no way to
filter it.
So everybody has to question things now
in a way that you never questioned
during the Walter cronkite era.
You know when people were giving the
news back when Ted Koppel was on the
air,
you weren't quite like Ted Koppel full
of Shit.
Like no one was saying that,
you know?
Right.
But Brian Williams is clearly full of
shit at.
That's why it's weirder now to follow
mainstream media because if you're not
saying that like,
how are you,
how do you have so much allegiance to
the machine that you would never
question it?
Like,
to me that's surprising.
Also,
that machine is the only vehicle for
these pharmaceutical companies.
They have to sandwich those commercials
in between,
you know,
whatever show you're watching,
that's know three 60 whatever the fuck
it is.
This guy's every 10 minutes and they
just sandwich.
I'm in there,
whereas you're not going to see those
commercials like no one's going to read
those drug ads on a podcast.
You're not going to say,
okay,
well hey,
been really nice talking to you and I
want to talk to you folks about abilify.
Are you right now thinking about being
suicidal and really want to cement those
thoughts and solidify them tea and make
actions or enough money?
That's right.
I shouldn't say it cause I don't even
know what I'm talking about.
You should be talking about this,
not me,
but here I am.
What does this abilify drug blame for?
Compulsive gambling,
eating shopping,
sex.
That's just life,
Bro.
How can you get blamed?
The abilify?
Here's one you can cause of this
impulsivity thing I'm telling you.
Yeah,
whoa.
Nearby a gambling habit costs are
between 1 million and 2 million in less
than five years.
You just suck it gambling lady,
stop blaming drugs.
The woman had been living in Las Vegas
since 1999 but she had never been to
town the gamble until she started taking
the drugs.
Get the fuck out of here.
That lady got a good lawyer,
she got a good lawyer and she's crazy.
They got 200 people in this lawsuit that
had off claimed that gambling has to get
in on it.
I want to take abilify so we can get
some of that cash.
There was a drug called re-equip and
there was a man in Ireland that took
this drug and said before the drug he
was a healthy heterosexual and after he
took the drug,
he became gay and a gambling addict and
he would engage in risky sex and he
would meet men and chat rooms and have
unprotected sex with them.
And then he got off the drug and was
like,
what did I do?
And he won the equivalent of us
somewhere in the neighborhood of
$600,000
from Glaxo Klein Smith.
Yeah.
Here it is,
man.
Says Parkinson's drug made him addicted
to gambling and gay sex.
What is that from 2000 what was it say
up there?
Yeah,
it was my memory.
That's what I remember.
I remember things that can turn me into
a gay sex and gambling junkie.
Like,
hey,
what else works good on Parkinson's pot?
Yeah.
Pot and pot doesn't do that.
Okay.
It's crazy.
This guy sued the shit out of him and
one that's what's crazy because I
believe it.
Well it's crazy is it's one dude hopes
for new trucks.
I love all the sandwich that now as many
as 1 million people in the United States
have Parkinson's and there's some new
stuff that doesn't turn aside.
Oh for sure.
Yeah.
I like how when you scroll down the
video keeps playing anyway.
Like they put a little video,
like you can't escape the video.
It's always sitting in the corner.
Like go ahead and press play.
Don't be timid.
Did Heaven doing this on the bottom?
Like where usually you'll see another
story or similar stories.
A sponsored story.
I can't even tell it.
Sponsored usually or you can't Ken
now on CNN,
they have a ton of those on a lot of
websites.
They have a ton of those.
Yeah,
it's pretty fascinating.
And it's like,
you know,
you won't believe what they look like
now and you're like,
God,
what do they look like now?
And then you have to go to like fucking
20 pages of what other people that look
like shit.
Now to get to this one person,
you might not
even,
they might even beyond that,
you know,
lemme just totally wasted 10 minutes of
your life.
You never get back.
Yeah.
I mean,
on medscape and these like seemingly
official medical websites,
there are Pharma ads that are,
uh,
appear to be diagnostic quizzes.
Do you have depression?
And then you go take the quiz.
And this is,
this is known,
you know,
has been exposed.
100% of people are identified pretty
much no matter what you click,
you're identified as being a candidate
for president.
It's not like,
dude,
you're fine.
Go play Frisbee and this objective
assessment and you're doing great.
You're doing great.
Yeah.
Oh my God,
I'm so glad that I don't have to sell
you drugs.
Right.
So what,
what do you hope to really get into
people's heads with this book and with
all this information and what you've
gone on in your journey,
if you had to like sum it up?
Well,
it's sort of like when you know better,
you do better.
It's like a Maya angelou quote.
It's like one of my favorite quotes.
That's a great quote.
It is because there's no shaming in that
is as good as the fake freud quote.
When you know better,
you do better.
It's really good when Fred said the word
asshole and it um,
so,
so with this information,
is there something in you that's like
excited about it or that says like,
hmm,
yeah,
there's something to that.
Because if there is,
then you should know what's possible,
right?
Because if you know it's possible,
then you will naturally move towards
that.
And the transformations that I have seen
and continue to see,
I mean like I could cry thinking about
it,
it's so deeply inspirational because
it's a kind of human experience that is
so redemptive.
It's like a real reclamation that is not
possible through the pharmaceutical
model in my opinion.
I want to tell you a quick story about
antibiotics cause you brought this up
earlier.
So I went to India recently,
right?
And I bought some antibiotics when you
got back and we never take,
I would never,
I don't take any farms.
You don't take antibiotics ever.
What if you've got an infection?
Like what?
If you've got staff then I'll tell you
exactly what would happen,
right?
So I went to India,
I brought my little kit with me.
Right.
Knowing that there's like,
and honestly like I,
I don't believe in germ theory in the
classical sense.
So I know and neither should anyone.
Germ theory is like if you're exposed to
a bad bug,
then you get sick,
right?
Exposure equals infection.
Right?
But you know,
pester himself on his deathbed said that
it was the terrain,
not the bug.
So what's the terrain?
The terrain is the context.
The terrain is your body in your
lifestyle and you know,
in your existence.
So that seems to be more relevant.
And then the discovery of the
microbiome,
like this inner ecology has totally,
we got to go back to the drawing board
completely in medicine because we didn't
know that before.
We soon as the discovery of the
microbiome.
It's about like 20 years,
20 years and 20 years.
We've the science of probiotics and,
and,
and understanding the importance of
consuming fermented foods and,
and you know,
super infections through antibiotic
overuse and the fact that you can't ever
get out from under this idea of just
killing the bad bugs.
It doesn't work.
And so the more you sanitize and you use
bleach and alcohol and prl and all that
stuff,
you're actually distorting things and
you're making it more likely for people
to develop what are called nosocomial
illnesses or infections,
which is hospital induced infections,
right?
This is the hospital as a sick
environment in part because we have a
wrong idea about how biological
ecosystems work.
There's no bad guys.
Everything works together.
It's like a metaphor for life.
In fact,
there aren't really any bad guys.
It's all,
you know,
is sort of part of the polarity of life
we need,
we need bad to know where good,
like it's that ancient philosophy.
So anyway,
so we go to India and I bring bentonite
clay,
I bring colloidal silver.
I bring a bunch of little silver.
Do you know that as a real,
that's the stuff that you like.
Do you use like a little electrodes,
you know,
stick the,
the water,
the stick to that or you just rely on
people to make that forward in a
responsible way then that turned some
dude glue?
Yeah.
Again,
it can do that if you ask the wrong,
if you're using large particles,
like an Avatar lady,
you're having a good work.
But anyway,
I think it would undermine my
credibility.
I don't know freaky.
I'm super healthy but I'm blue is fuck
that poor guy.
He does.
Oh my gosh,
that's a reversible apparently.
Yeah.
That's not what we're going for.
That's why as a diy it may not be the
best idea.
So does colonial silver,
what's the benefits of cool?
So,
okay,
so like herbal [inaudible] like
botanical,
you know,
sort of like antimicrobials if you want
to call them that.
They don't kill stuff there.
I think they have like a rebalancing
effect,
but there,
you know for like,
you know,
CBO,
which is small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth.
It's like a thing people are struggling
with that a lot of functional medicine
doctors treat.
There is randomized trial looking at
antibiotics versus herbal botanicals
showing herbal botanicals are as
effective.
So why would you ever bother with the
risks of antibiotics,
which are legion?
I mean they're massive risks.
Botanicals are specifically,
especially things like oil of Oregano
for example.
It's like one of the better studied
ones,
you know,
grapefruit seed extract there,
Pau d'arco,
there's a whole number of them.
Golden Seal like in Asia that have these
properties and a lot of supplements just
sort of put them all together.
Right.
Okay.
So I'm making this story too long.
So I go to India,
I bring all this stuff right.
And one of the women,
it's like a Kundalini trip and one of
the women gets really sick like Cru,
like projectile vomiting and like
screaming in pain.
Like bad scene.
I left right before you got the
screaming in pain.
I'm sorry,
I thought she was just puking.
I know it was,
it was,
she was super sick.
Right.
And even the Indian dude who was sorta
like our chaperone in a way,
like a friend of the woman who led the
led the trip was like,
oh,
we got to bring her to the hospital
hospital.
And you're like,
no,
I've got to give her clue silver.
And I was like,
gimme 12 hours,
just really cute.
I looked him in the eyes,
it's like gave me 12 hours and I know
her well enough to know that she would
be down for this approach.
Okay.
So,
and she was not afraid,
important detail.
She's not afraid.
She was super uncomfortable,
but she wasn't like freaking out and
like,
oh my God,
we're gonna die.
Okay.
She just thought she was sick,
which is true.
Right.
So in 12 hours she was completely,
well,
we were in the car for a two hour trip,
going to like another part of northern
India.
And how did you cure or treat her?
She may very well have done it herself.
And,
and the ritual of these supplements and
Bentonite Clay and whatever could have
just been an accessory.
Who,
who knows.
The truth is that if she had taken
antibiotics,
which she never did,
if she had taken them reflexively,
she probably would have been sick
longer.
And she then ultimately when she got
better,
what have attributed to,
to the end of antibiotics.
Right,
right,
right.
So she never would have had the
opportunity to just see what her body's
capable of.
So we make these assumptions about
pharmaceuticals in the absence of any
baseline evidence,
information or even experience to help
us understand what our bodies are
capable of.
But what if someone catches one of these
antibiotic resistant,
very aggressive
strains like Marissa.
I mean,
you know,
so,
so my partner has a website called green
med info comm,
right?
What is it called?
Green Med info.green
Med info.com
and he catalogs all of the data from Pub
med.gov
on these natural substances evidence
that shows that something like garlic,
you know,
cause there's a study he put up on on
and I think it was like garlic and maybe
honey or something you would laugh at,
right?
Doctor,
Rhonda Patrick went through this and she
talked about on the podcast,
she had a,
an persistent staph infection that would
not go away and treat.
She treated it with garlic and um,
uh,
in a topical form and it cured it when
nothing else would.
And she had gone through this host of
antibiotics that really wrecked her gut
biome and she was really fucked up for
like a year because of it.
And she treated with a topical
application of garlic,
which is crazy.
And it sounds crazy until you actually
learned that there's,
you wouldn't know that there's actually
science to support that.
So there's a ton of science to support
natural medicine.
I don't know who funds these studies.
It's crazy that they're even done
because there certainly isn't Pharma
money behind them,
but they are done.
And if you know about them,
it might help you to make an informed
decision.
But this is reflexive assumption that
well,
pharmaceutical medicine is the only
legit choice if it gets bad enough is
conditioning.
That's all I'm saying.
It's a,
it's a conditioned assumption.
And if you have an experience that
defies that,
then you'll make different decisions for
yourself in the future.
But you have to have like that woman
will probably make different decisions
for herself in the future because now
she trusts her body like just a little
bit more,
you know,
she's that much less afraid of all of
the horror stories.
The fearmongering is the greatest
marketing device,
you know,
employed by the industry is scaring you
into what if you don't do it.
Bunch of people that like when they do
catch Murcia or something like that and
then get devastated like the right move
is to get on an IV antibiotic.
Like is isn't that sometimes
you just told me a story where that's
not true.
What told you a story.
Okay,
so then what is one but it's one and she
had a topical issue but if it's one in
you're the one then that's important
information for yourself.
It certainly is.
I mean antibiotics
but I mean don't,
don't they serve a purpose in some
functions sometimes.
I mean,
you don't want to throw the baby out
with the bath water,
right?
I mean,
if someone has some rapid aggressive
infection,
a bacterial infection,
if we only used antibiotics for true
life or death emergencies,
we would have a very different situation
on our hands than what we have now,
which is a combination of,
you know,
devastating our ecosystem.
You know,
making people gravely ill because they
have very serious and totally
unpredictable side effects including
longterm neurologic side effects.
Um,
you know,
the,
what's even going on with our livestock,
like we are in a mess with our worship
of this idea of,
of,
and you know what antibiotic means.
It means against life.
Like literally there's something wrong
headed about that mentality.
And so it comes back to philosophy.
Like,
if you want to believe in,
in war,
you know,
you want to war against your body,
you want to war against and blame all
the bad people who do all this bad
things and you want to lock them up in
prisons and you want to hate the,
you know,
Arabs and terrorists.
And if that's fair,
but if that's your general vibe,
then it's gonna make sense to take
medications like that for you.
Right.
But I,
you know,
have plenty of colleagues and myself,
we have a different philosophy.
So that's why it comes down to it's a
religion,
you know,
it really comes down to your belief
system.
So your philosophy is improve the health
of the gut biome taken natural
antibiotics,
things like garlic,
things like Oregano oil,
things that are nature.
Yeah,
right,
right.
Get back to the continuum.
Like,
you know,
there's this notion that there's like a,
a path where meant to walk,
you know,
where we sort of follow our,
what our ancestors sort of set us up for
and we've strayed from it big time.
And,
and we're in some ways being reminded,
you know,
that we can't go too much farther
without like struggling pretty
seriously.
I think one of the big
points that you just made,
which is really huge,
is that if we only used antibiotics when
necessary in life or death situations,
we wouldn't have the issues that we have
right now with livestock,
with,
with people's House and the people take
z packs like it's going out of style.
I mean they take them out to take
tylenol for a headache.
I know so many people that take
antibiotics,
they just throw him down.
Oh,
I feel so much better.
I took a z pack.
Like you might feel better because you
going to feel better anyway,
and the z pack he just threw on top of
the mix and decided that that was what
was taking you over the top.
That's right.
Meanwhile,
it's like in the water supply now is it
z packs,
but it's like microscopic levels that
you can't really,
they're not psychoactive,
right,
isn't it?
There was just this,
there was just something I put on social
media.
It was like studying fish that are
exposed to antidepressant water and they
became like more aggressive.
Something like,
you know,
fish aren't made happier by but,
but the point is that antidepressants
are just in the water supply now to
products apparently in dosages relevant
to the clinical expression of fish
behavior.
I don't know.
But Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
I mean there's no free lunch.
There's no free lunch with Pharma I
think.
But if you're in a fishing that's good
cause you want fish to be aggressive.
I mean maybe they don't want to be,
I'll give a fuck what they want.
I'm going to eat chill.
I've never seen one fisher just eating
things.
Mostly other fish are a bunch of goddamn
cannibals.
All of them.
Um,
yeah.
Silly,
silly thoughts.
Thanks for indulging in those,
by the way.
Um,
and thanks for coming on here.
I really appreciate it.
We just sent three hours.
It was fun.
Wow.
Quite an attention span.
So you do not need to add or all you're
doing just I'm scared of that or all.
I'd had two cups of coffee though,
but if I had adderall,
I just don't want to try one day,
but it's,
I'm terrified of it and Canadian study
just came out that if,
if you take a stimulant,
you're 13 times more likely to be
prescribed and it's a psychotic and four
times more likely to be prescribed
Canadian.
Like regular people.
There's totally different kind of
person.
Very important.
Super important to confounding variables
from the woods.
They're forest folks.
I know.
All right Kelly,
so one more time to tell people.
What does the name of your book where
you can get it?
I'm sure you're going to get a lot of
positive and negative stay offline for a
couple of days.
Just I do have your back.
I'm just telling you I don't want,
I don't want you to get hit with the
trolls.
No,
listen,
first of all,
it's important.
It's my disclaimer that I'm not here to
tell anyone what to do,
right?
It's just about informed consent.
And if you know all the information,
you want it to continue making your
choice do you were saying,
but I do believe people are entitled to
all of the Information and I didn't know
about it when I was prescribing,
so I carry that charge,
you know?
So my book is called the mind of your
own and,
um,
the rest of my nonsense on my website,
just Kelly Brogan,
md.com.
All right.
Beautiful.
Thank you so much.
Enjoy the total pleasure.
All right,
my friends,
that's it.
We'll be back tomorrow with hilarious
and drew Santino don't till then get off
those pills.
You fucked or don'ts.